au 666 à l'article le premier je suis
saisi d'un amendement 666 monsieur finir
il est défendu
monsieur meyer
je n'ai rien entendu dans les propos
donc allez-y en en vue le président j'ai
été mis en cause directement et je te
les jets j'ai simplement et je tiens à
le dire tellement regretté que le
président du groupe de la france
insoumise maison blanche en il ya
quelques il ya quelques mois de cela a
dérapé je le regrette parce qu'il
n'aurait pas dû le faire lorsque les
élections en angleterre et que son et
que son et que cent et que son poulain a
été battu l'accusé les juifs ça c'est un
dérapage antisémite d'adhérents journée
lorsque l'on parle on parle d'un
logiciel il serait bien qu'il est en
effet très performant on a le grand prix
mais après certains attentats
terroristes aujourd'hui j'ai été mis en
cause encore directement ça suffit leur
obsession des juifs et ça suffit
l'ambition d'israël monsieur bras d'eau
je crois qu'il faut qu'on passe assez
vite à nos travaux parce que on a de
quoi s'occuper un merci monsieur le
président c'est un rappel heureusement
sur l'organisation de nos de nos travaux
nous étions ce matin ici même à
poursuivre l'examen des amendements et
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat auditionnés monsieur ministre de
la santé sur le projet de loi de gestion
de la crise sanitaire et donc j'aimerais
beaucoup que le ministre nous éclaire
sur les mesures qu'il a présentée devant
le sénat puisque l'assemblée nationale
n'a pas encore elle même fini d'examiner
le projet de loi qui nous est
présentement présenter tout ça pour dire
en plus du faible nombre d'heures qui a
été consacré d'abord en commission et
puis initialement ici même dans
l'hémicycle pour faire passer au forceps
un texte qui mérite un débat approfondi
tout ça pour dire qu'il ya une forme de
mépris du travail parlementaire que je
trouve assez regrettable sur ce sujet
très important
merci donc nous en étions 666 monsieur
cyril et défendu vous avez la parole
merci monsieur riant oui je je soutiens
donc que je représente le vice-président
que de la spéciale pour un amendement
qui est très court qui vise à exempter
la restauration scolaire au même titre
que les autres restaurations collectives
dans la porter défavorable chez le
ministre
je mets aux voix qui est pour contre
rejeté les 667 monsieur généreux
oui merci monsieur président le présent
amendement a pour objet d'exempter les
débiles version de la contrainte du
passé ni terre regarde la difficulté à
le faire respecter
mais le rapporteur défavorable machine
ministre également monsieur jumelles en
réponse je vous êtes lui kulik vous
tirer plus vite que votre ombre monsieur
le président je voulais réagir à
l'amendement sur la restauration
les maires ont mis beaucoup
d'intelligence d'esprit de
responsabilité
je crois enfin pour le dire pour mettre
en oeuvre les protocoles sanitaires dans
les restaurants scolaires et c'est pas
simple en fonction de la taille de la
commune de j'ai de plus en plus de
remonter dans ma circonscription
deux maires de petites communes qui me
disent qu'à la rentrée prochaine
le protocole sanitaire va les conduire à
refuser des gamins à quand une faute de
place parce que des fois quand on est en
base de service trois services mais
quatre services ça ne rentre pas et donc
ils mettent en place des ddd mesure qui
vise à exclure des mômes de la cantine
alors il commence par les mômes qui sont
pas de la commune et qui sont scolarisés
par dérogation scolaire
et puis ensuite ils établissent des
critères qu'ils essaient le plus
objectif possible et donc je voulais
attirer votre attention sur cette
question en vous demandant de faire en
sorte avec votre collègue d'avoir un
diagnostic sur le nombre d'enfants qui
vont être ainsi privé de restauration
scolaire et et sa corrobore donc
l'amendement déposé
précédemment par nos collègues de droite
sur
le fait que si on applique le pacs
sanitaires à la restauration scolaire
le risque est grand d'aggraver l'accès à
la cantine dont on sait que c'est un
menu équilibré essentiel pour un grand
nombre de gamins dans le cycle scolaire
donc voilà je voulais attirer votre
attention là dessus monsieur le ministre
jamais de wall street et des commissions
gouvernement qui est pour quand rejetée
alors avant de donner la parole
gouvernement le ministre indique
simplement que sur cet amendement 274
avènement du groupe udi indépendant il y
aura un scrutin public
le scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée monsieur ministre devait
la parole monsieur le député pour vous
j'ai bien entendu le message sur les sur
les cantines le présent amendement
visait à supprimer une disposition qui
était introduite contre l'avis du
gouvernement et contre l'avis du
rapporteur en commission qui empêcherait
la mise en place du pass salutaire pour
des activités de restauration et de
débit de boisson en dessous d'un certain
seuil de clients on sait que la notion
mais
merci monsieur président comme je lé
indiqué je suis à titre personnel
défavorable la position de ceux qui est
inspiré de facto certains établissements
du pas sanitaires à l'exception des
centres commerciaux ou la mesure se
justifie pour permettre l'accès aux
biens de première nécessité
pourquoi la situation est elle
différente pour les restaurants parce
que ce seuil empêchera une application
générale de la mesure et que certains
restaurants et bars ne pourront se voir
appliquer le passé ni terre c'est donc
le risque au coeur de la quatrième vague
de les voir fermer injustement
je suis donc un titre personnel
favorable à cet amendement néanmoins je
porte le mandat de la commission qui a
adopté cette disposition cet hymne est
donc un avis défavorable
maintenant gouvernementale défavorable à
l'amendement de notre collègue du
philippot c'est clair monsieur bras
d'eau avait demandé la parole oui merci
monsieur le président cet amendement du
gouvernement est assez symptomatique
finalement d'une position rigide qui est
adoptée sur cette question du pass
sanitaires notamment dans les
restaurants supprimés l'idée d'un seuil
défini par décret ce qui n'est pas plus
contraignantes dans cette matière que
dans d'autres puisqu'il ya plein
d'autres dispositions on renvoie aux
réglementaire un certain nombre de
mesures d'application
ça veut dire finalement vouloir imposer
le pass and i ter aux premiers clients
présents dans un restaurant mais quelle
est la cohérence à vouloir imposer dans
un restaurant qui par exemple n'aurait
que vingt couverts répartis entre une
terrasse et et une salle où la
possibilité y compris d'écarter les gens
ce qui d'ailleurs a été fait très bien
par les restaurateurs
lors du des confirmands avec d'abord
l'ouverture des terrasses et ensuite
l'ouverture des salles intérieures
quelle est la cohérence avec la
possibilité qu'auront des personnes des
particuliers d'organiser
un repas avec traiteur dans un lieu où
ils pourront être 50 et pourquoi pas 100
et qu'il ne fera pas l'objet puisqu'il
n'est pas une manifestation publique qui
ne fera pas l'objet d'un pass annie
terre on voit bien là la limite de la
position systématique rigide qui
adoptent le gouvernement en matière de
passes sanitaires et c'est nous qui
sommes les promoteurs du passani terre
qui vous lisent on nous avons toujours
considéré que pour que se passa ni terre
puisse accepter par nos concitoyens
encore une fois il faut qu'il soit
cohérent lisible de bon sens et qu'ils
soient souples c'est pas une question
seulement de risque sanitaire ne me
faites pas croire que mettre dix
personnes dans une salle écarté on a
plus de risques que de laisser les gens
s'agglutiner dans une rue merci monsieur
le président oui on a l'impression avec
cet amendement du gouvernement et je
reprends ce que disait le collègue
brindeau et qui me souffle les propos on
a vraiment l'impression que dès le
premier client ou à 3,4 on fera une
vraie fausse ouverture
faudrait quand même à afficher les
choses très très clairement et du reste
ça m'amène à une question qui est un peu
en marge de notre texte mais qui est
bien liée à l'ensemble du texte mais qui
est bien lié aux passes depuis hier on a
une jauge de 50 qui s'applique
on a un certain nombre de festivals qui
qui devait avoir lieu et qui se trouve
annulés les uns après les autres
qu en est il des frais engagés par les
associations les collectivités qui sont
en réalité contraintes dans un certain
nombre de cas à annuler les festivals où
ces festivités qui était prévu alors on
va dire que légalement il est possible
sous contrainte mais comme oran éviter
les contraintes sont si fortes ce n'est
pas possible de le faire quelles
responsabilités de l'état quelle
indemnisation quelle prise en charge
eh bien je tends des réponses à cette
première question et je retourne les
éléments sur les restaurateurs le jour
où vous nous dites ces deux ou trois
clients point barre à l'heure et
pourquoi pas même si on caricature un
peu en disant ainsi quelle quelle
responsabilité de l'état et puis surtout
quel manque de confiance à l'égard
des restaurateurs si un des chefs
d'entreprise merci nous allons donc
procéder au vote sur 1 914 ta vote
électronique chacun a pu regagner sa
place
ali favorable à titre personnel du
rapporteur d'un amendement
gouvernemental au comptant est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 106-104
majorité 53 pour 55 contre 49 donc
l'amendement gouvernemental est adopté
il fait donc tomber l'autre amendement
qui était dans la discussion commune le
1036 madame dupont brisé l'épaule 2036
mélanie bon si monsieur le président
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
cet amendement traite de la situation
particulière du bâtiment et des travaux
publics qui on le sait tous a subi la
crise sanitaire comme beaucoup comme
beaucoup d'autres secteurs et d'ailleurs
cet amendement peut consigner concerner
d'autres secteurs d'activité le btp a
des preuves de manoeuvre aujourd'hui les
problèmes de matières premières des
retards de chantier certains vont même
travaillé au mois d'août ces pme ces
entreprises du btp ont des chantiers qui
peuvent être éloignés et les équipes
peuvent être en déplacement à la semaine
en hébergement à l'hôtel et surtout en
restauration quotidienne en restaurant
beaucoup de jeunes professionnels ne
sont pas forcément vacciner encore y
compris en anjou même si on se vaccine
beaucoup monsieur ministre en anjou et
je salue le civisme de nos de nos des de
nos angevin on peut avoir un ange ou un
vaccin sous quinze jours c'est quelque
chose de possible aujourd'hui il ya des
places mais ensuite non quinze jours de
vaccins trois semaines pour la seconde
dose une semaine pour l'effectivité du
passeport sanitaire complet ça fait six
semaines de contraintes et du coup
autant de semaines et autant de journées
où ses collaborateurs devront faire
des tests en attendant le passeport
complet cet amendement propose donc que
des conventions puisse s signé entre les
employeurs et les restaurateurs sur le
modèle de ce qu'on a fait pendant le les
confinements précédent pour permettre
une restauration convenable de ses
salariés sans obligation donc de faire
un test pcr tous les deux jours je crois
qu'il nous faut de la rigueur pour
encadrer bien entendu et se prémunir
contre ce virus mais aussi du
pragmatisme pour ne pas rendre la vie de
ses salariés
impossible je vous remercie merci à mon
avis deux majeurs à porter merci
monsieur le président le dispositif
d'exception pour la restauration
collective passera par un décret du
premier ministre alors que ce que vous
proposez sera fixé par une convention
collective ce qui n'est pas satisfaisant
juridiquement donc avis défavorable mais
ma vie l'amendement et maintenez je
l'aimais aux voix tout d'abord les
marcheurs marche sur la tête fin tout à
l'heure ils ont voit dans les cordes
ils ont fait dans les cordes un
amendement qui vise à ne pas appliquer
le pass sanitaires pour les mômes qui
mangent à la cantine et nous explique
que pour les salariés du btp ça va être
problématique que d'accéder à la
restauration collective mais cette
problématique parce que vous avez géré
ça n'importe comment pour plein de gens
deuxièmement je veux vous faire part de
la mise en oeuvre concrète de vos
mauvaises mesures hier au château musée
de dieppe un château extraordinaire où
on peut voir des peintres
impressionnistes cuissard octobre 200
personnes se pointe dans la journée 50
n'avaient pas été vaccinés 50 ont donc
été conformément au décret prix renvoyer
alors étude sur la plage pour ne pas
accéder au musée avec y compris des
crispations dans les files d'attentes
entre ceux qui étaient vaccinés qui
voulait rentrer vite dans le château et
ceux qui étaient à qu'il fallait
expliquer qu'il n'avait rien à faire
dans le château puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
vaccinés donc un le clivage de la
population est au rendez vous deux on
essaie de dire au préfet écoutez c'est
un grand musée très grands musées on
établit des jauges à 40 pour rentrer
dans le château on organise sa dans la
journée y compris avec d'autres réseaux
des guides conférenciers et à ce moment
là on respecte les jauges et on permet à
chacun de découvrir ce magnifique
château et refus parce qu'on prend en
compte la taille de le rp pour fixer les
seuils au lieu de prendre en compte la
réalité concrète pour permettre à chacun
d'accéder à ce magnifique lieu culturel
voilà là l'illustration concrète d'abord
de contradictions que vous n'assumez pas
et d'une gestion technocratique de la
crise que donner des leçons depuis le
début du débat qui est pour et qui est
contre 1 961 n'est pas défendu le 622
coquerel un amendement qui vise à
supprimer la linea di ce qui concerne le
les salons et les foires
donc ils se lisent a supris la demande
du pape sanitaire qui va dans la logique
de notre refus du passani terre j'en
profite pour poser puisque là monsieur
vers en est là et je voulais lui
proposer une question ce matin ils
étaient partis donc je vais le faire là
dans les salons chacun conviendra que
c'est des milieux fermés
d'après ce que vous nous avez dit ce
matin est ce que vous avez revendiqué à
nouveau dans ces lieux fermés
une fois qu'on en trois avec le pass
annie terre on n'aura pas être protégés
bien on aura pas être masqué et ça fait
écho à à ce que j'évoquais hier du peu
de monsieur castex l'expliquant de
prémisses expliquant qu'on ne sera plus
nombreux et plus considérés comme cas
content
vous avez répondu que vous vous référiez
ainsi à la haute autorité médicale en
notant que le finder à 86% empêchaient a
priori l'apparition de cas
asymptomatiques je vous ferai remarquer
que c'est symptomatique et non pas
symptomatique autrement dit on ne
connaît pas aujourd'hui le pourcentage
de gens qui souffre either peuvent en
réalité continuer à transmettre le virus
parce qu elles sont asymptomatiques et
ne le savent pas moi je considère je
continue à considérer que vu ce que nous
avons comme informations autour d'eux
qui nous remontent notamment des pays
d'étrangers
le principe de précaution monsieur véran
parce que les autorités médicales dit
une chose et c'est à nous de décider de
ce qu'on fait en fonction de ses
conseils je remarque d'ailleurs qu'à
certains moments depuis un an et demi
vous n'avez pas suivi les autorités
médicales sur la question de
l'obligation des masques au départ sur
la question à un moment donné du nombre
de jours nécessaires pour s'isoler je me
rappelle qu'il y avait vous n'avez pas
suivi d'actes donc là vous décidez de le
suivre
moi j'aimerais que vous nous confirmer
ça parce que vous avez d'une histoire
jugera josé pas l'histoire mais le temps
jugera les paroles je pense que dans la
situation où on est aujourd'hui de
flambées épidémiques vous prenez un
énorme risque en demandant aux personnes
de plus est de protéger dès lors qu'ils
ont pas sanitaires j'aimerais que vous
nous répéter que c'est votre
responsabilité aujourd'hui de le faire
merci merci alors cet amendement du
rapporteur
merci me suis président je passe panique
sanitaire permet de conforter la reprise
qui est à mon avis tant attendu par les
professionnels de ce secteur d'activité
donc c'est un avis défavorable
ce ministre défavorable jamais donc
voilà 26 ans 22 qui est pour quand je
t'ai le 1084 monsieur défendu ginouvier
chat défendu dans les andes eu des
invités abîmes du rapporteur
défavorable également il est retiré
il est retiré la ville et ils y arrivent
pardonnez moi et le ministre il est
favorable également
f
sagesse je vais oublier ça oui juste
pour expliquer un instant c'est un
amendement porté par le groupe la
réplique en marche sous l'impulsion de
notre collègue jean françois et yahoo
qui vise à introduire et à permettre de
mettre en place les espaces sanitaires
pour les séminaires notamment les
séminaires d'entreprises
une demande forte donc c'est cette
demande que nous portons à travers cet
amendement jour merci râble je mets donc
voir le 1084 favorable commission un
gouvernement qui est pour contre adopté
le 689 la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
le sujet a déjà été évoqué le sera
encore certainement dans les prochains
amendements et je ne reprendrai pas tous
les arguments répété en maintes fois sur
les bancs de cette assemblée sur les
risques de propagation grandement
diminué en extérieur donc le présent
amendement propose de restreindre
l'obligation aux espaces couverts
je vous remercie merci le défi la
commune de 1513 un caillou défendu mais
monsieur le jeu a doctor défavorable
pour les deux défavorable également
pardonnez moi mais là après les moyens
et c'est être en bonne et merci
vayssettes président est très rapidement
effectivement c'est pour demander
l'exception des foires et salons qui ont
lieu en plein air on a déjà eu la
discussion tout à l'heure à nombreuses
reprises donc je vais pas m'éterniser
mais il me semble que les lieux de
contamination étant enfant en
particulier et en priorité les lieux
fermés on pourrait faire une exception
pour les foires et salons qui sont lieux
qui ont lieu en extérieur je vous
remercie et favorable pour l'enfant pour
que le rapporteur et le gouvernement je
mets au voit successivement ces
amendements le 689 qui est pour quand je
t'ai mis ensemble 13 même avis même
votre 40 mais ma vie même
hop nous en revenons maintenant à ana au
940 monsieur corbières passé merci
monsieur pause ou non une question nous
continuons à interroger notamment
monsieur le ministre et les
responsabilités qu'ils occupent
je reprend peu ou prou les propos d'eric
coquerel
monsieur le ministre vous assumez en
quelque sorte que selon vous si tôt que
l'on est vaccinés on n'a plus besoin
d'avoir des protections qui ces derniers
temps ont été sollicités ayant montré
quand même une certaine efficacité tout
de même nous connaissons nombre de cas
où des gens vaccinés continue à être
porteurs du virus le diffuser à même
être porteurs du virus
symptomatique pouvez vous alors vous
nous avait rétorqué que différentes
autorités médicales considéré qu' à ce
stade ça n'était plus nécessaire mais
nous voulons votre opinion à vous qu'il
soit dit devant la représentation
nationale car nous trouvons pieds là une
forme d'incohérence à ce stade malgré
tout après les mesures de limitation des
libertés publiques que vous mettez dans
ce texte vous considérer pour autant que
ce lorsqu'on est vacciné notamment dans
des lieux fermés on n'a plus à se
protéger
pourquoi nous insistons là-dessus c'est
que l'impression que nous avons c'est
dans l'argumentation qui accompagnent
votre dispositif qui a en quelque sorte
véritablement deux types de concitoyens
qui auront lieu ce qu'ils ont refusé de
se faire vacciner et qui seront
multiplié les tracasseries et ceux qui
après avoir été vacciné pourront sans
plus aucune protection continue à
évoluer ce qui risque d'approfondir
véritablement et de créer l'existence de
deux citoyens avec des libertés
radicalement différente ce qui même du
point de vue des mesures de sécurité
pour stopper la circulation du virus
n'est pas raisonnable donc pouvez-vous
répondre à la question que le collègue
coquerel à poser que j'essaye aussi de
réitérer merci donc
monsieur à porter merci monsieur le
président ceux qui travaillent dans les
services établissements de santé sur
tout et médico sociaux seront vaccinés
ceux qui rendent visite
or on a pas sauf évidemment en cas
d'urgence donc l'avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
répondre parce que sinon je pense que je
serai réinterroger je voudrais qu'on
puisse avancer dans le texte
j'ai compris comment ça fonctionne j'ai
répondu ce matin longuement sur ce sujet
au président belge qui m'interrogeait
donc je vous je voulais dit le haut
conseil de santé publique considère que
dans un lieu fermé où le passage iter
s'applique si le passé bien respecté on
peut tomber le masque
j'ai dit que nous avions dans le décret
pris nuances de poids qui est de petite
donner la possibilité au préfet de
maintenir le port du masque obligatoire
y compris en cas de passer ni terre en
intérieur considérant les situations
épidémiques et j'ai dit que les préfets
serez amené à se prononcer bientôt nous
sommes en train de travailler avec eux
sur cette question
ma conviction personnelle importe peu
mais je vous avoue vous en avez déjà une
partie de la réponse puisque dans le
décret que j'ai signé j'ai mis cette
attention particulière à la
réversibilité de l'obligation du port de
masques dans les endroits fermés
impliquant le past sanitaire donc voilà
je vous ai parfois la réponse est dans
la question
merci je réussisse
oui merci monsieur je poursuis la
question ce qu'on a on a eu des éléments
tout à l'heure par le ministre eric n'en
a été tirée du conseil scientifique vous
souvenez monsieur min sur la question de
la de la contagiosité pour du virus du
variant delta quand on est vacciné et il
y avait 80 8% de vous aviez 90% de
chances de moins d'avoir des symptômes
du variant delta et on est à pour les
cas graves hospitalisation dans le même
document 96%
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est vous
même qui l'avait dit qu'à une capacité
de contagiosité de 10 puissance 3
supérieur par rapport aux autres variant
et que donc on n'a pas donc on n'a pas
la statistique aujourd'hui de la
contagiosité pour quelqu'un qui est
vacciné asymptomatique et qui serait
asymptomatique et on est en train de
voir effectivement que dans des zones où
les gens sont massivement vacciner le
variant delta se propage
on peut émettre donc assez normalement
l'hypothèse que probablement vu la
célérité du variant 20 à 30% de la
population je sais pas comment vous
estimez c'est à vous de votre côté
pourrait attraper le variant delta
quand bien même ils seraient vaccinés
bonne nouvelle si vous êtes vacciné vous
avait 90% de chances d'avoir d'avoir des
symptômes légers mais vous avez quand
même de ne pas avoir des symptômes
légers et vous avez 96 % de chances de
ne pas avoir des symptômes graves
sauf que si vous faites 4% de 30% de la
population
en fait en valeur absolue ça fait
potentiellement plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes qui pourraient
avoir des cas graves avec ce variant
delta tout en étant vacciner et je crois
pas qu'on ait 700 mille places en
réanimation
je suis même plutôt sûr qu'on les a pas
et donc je pense je pose des genres on
reposera la question parce que six
retirer le masque
vous n'êtes pas qu'à contacter vous
pouvez l'enlever parce que vous avez pas
sanitaire alors que vous pouvez quand
même avoir le variant delta qui fait que
potentiellement
vale 4% je vois là jeu et je pense que
du coup la soudure maison pour dépasser
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour contre rejeté alors sur les 372 est
identique et la demande du groupe la
france a soumis un scrutin public
monsieur et ménagers présente de 372 oui
monsieur le président on a tous en tête
la terrible épreuve humaine je dirais
plutôt inhumaine que nous avons
traversés lors des précédents
confinement qui nous empêchait d'aller
voir nos proches hospitalisés dans les
maisons de retraite dans les ehpad
c'était terrible et l'idée c'est de
supprimer l'article 11 de la loi de
façon en fin de l'article de façon à se
permettre aux accompagnants qui vont se
rendre dans les hôpitaux qui vont se
rendre au chevet des malades ou les
personnes âgées de ne pas être soumis au
pass sanitaires
à condition bien sûr de respecter les
règles de distanciation de lavage des
mains et de port du masque d'antiques
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement très important si on est tous
d'accord qu'il faut amener vers la
vaccination des personnes ont commencé
le chemin vaccinale mais le temps qu'ils
arrivent jusqu'au bout n'auront pas le
pass sanitaire qui mieux que les
établissements de santé pour accompagner
ces personnes qui n'ont pas fini ce
cheminement pour leur proposer un masque
ffp2 une surblouse et leur dire comment
faire pour protéger le patient pour
éviter que le patient et ou attrape le
virus et je vous dis ça parce que on va
se retrouver avec votre histoire de pas
sanitaires ou les soignants vont appeler
les familles en dix ans madame monsieur
il faut que vous veniez votre papa votre
maman votre conjoint c'est les derniers
moments et on va refuser les pas les
familles parce que dans ce dernier
moment la personne n'aura pas de passes
sanitaires on en parle on en parle pas
et moi je veux pas vivre ça mes
collègues ne veulent pas vivre ça et on
sait habiller les familles pendant la
première la deuxième et la troisième
j'étais en service réanimation je peux
vous dire on sait leur dire comment
porter le basque ffp2 on sait leur
mettez les sur blues on sait tout faire
pour protéger si la personne n'a pas ne
pas sanitaires on saura les habiller en
conséquence
et j'ai envie de penser que en plus pour
on saura protéger les patients voté cet
amendement de bon sens oui merci
monsieur le président là aussi c'est je
voudrais évoquer également l'accès aux
soins tous les français comme aux
collègues et ménager des sont égaux
devant la loi qu'il s'agit des soins
urgents au programme et il est
nécessaire je prends de préserver ce
droit aux soins quels que soient les
conditions sanitaires et quel que soit
le statut vaccinal du patient empêcher
les malades d'avoir accès aux hôpitaux
et aux autres établissements ce fait si
leur pathologie n'est pas urgente
reviens à mon avis à leur faire encourir
des risques potentiellement
irréversibles pour leur santé par
ailleurs depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire l'interdiction des visites
dans les établissements de santé a
profondément choqué les français
allant voter sur
112 est identique c'était un vote
électronique je l'avais annoncé chacun
puis regagner sa place c'est bon
le scrutin est ouvert l'un scrutin est
clos voici les résultats votants
cinquante six degrees 127 majorité 60
menace pour 70 contre 67 dans
l'amendement et d'en adopter
le mille cent soixante sept tombes 698
tombe aussi les 1018 j'ai 2018 en 1913
913 sa tombe pas ça
alors nous reprenons au 46 et sur le 46
est identique à la demande du groupe
l'est républicain il y aura un scrutin
public le scrutin et annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
madame ménard à la parole pour 46
attendu tombe pas
on reprend garde madame ménard sur le 46
il est descendu j'ai un amendement de
suppression défendu messieurs le seul 1
389 défendu vous avez oui simplement le
groupe et leur défense cet amendement
merci le 616 madame pyatt défendu le 740
monsieur rupert vous avez la parole oui
je vais le défendre c'est important
parle là de l'élargissement du poste
sanitaire aux transports publics à
longue distance
or voyager est une liberté mais c'est
aussi pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
une nécessité déjà pour tous ceux qui
travaillent
il ya des milliers de nos concitoyens
qui tous les jours prennent des trains
des tgv notamment parce qu'il ya une
distance longue entre leur domicile et
leur lieu de travail
c'est aussi un moyen de déplacement
d'urgence pour des motifs familiaux et
personnels et donc celui qui n'aura pas
le temps de faire un test
par exemple dans un cas d'urgence et ce
qui pourra quand même monter dans un
train s'il doit se rendre urgemment dans
une autre ville du pays
on sait que les tests ne sont pas
toujours accessibles si facilement il
faut trouver évidemment une pharmacie à
côté de chez soi qui sont ouvertes
et puis surtout je m'interroge sur
l'impact sanitaire d'un tel
élargissement du pass puisque beaucoup
d'études montrent qu'avec le respect des
gestes barrières
il n'y a que peu de risques de
contamination dans les transports
publics
c'est donc je trouve un élargissement
particulièrement dur pour nos
concitoyens qui va les empêcher
dans leurs déplacements pour la simple
raison qu'ils n'ont pas été vaccinés
notamment d'ailleurs au mois d'août ou
qu'ils ont un test à jour récent donc je
crois que nous devrions enlevé
absolument les transports publics à
longue distance du pass sanitaires
monsieur boudreau la parole pour le 1158
monsieur le président j'aurai besoin de
l'éclairage de monsieur le ministre
concernant les déplacements entre
l'outre-mer et la métropole sur les
personnes vaccinées n'ont pas besoin de
tests pcr ou antigénique dans le sens
réunion paris par contre ils ont besoin
d'un test pc ou antigénique pour le
retour alors j'aimerais avoir votre
éclairage votre réponse là dessus s'il
vous plaît merci merci messieurs à
porter sur ces amendements qui pression
merci monsieur peillon alors que le
passeport sanitaire ne concernait
jusqu'à présent que les grands
déplacements extra hexagonaux le présent
article inclus dans le champ du pass
sanitaires les déplacements de longue
distance par transports publics au sein
de l'ensemble du territoire national ne
seront donc pas conserver les
dépassements publics locaux du quotidien
en transport en commun notamment ni
l'ensemble des déplacements en voiture
cette disposition s'appliquera donc
principalement déplacements en avion en
autocar ou en train pour des trajets de
longue distance sont visés dans cette
perspective sanitaire objective les
déplacements programmés qui regroupe les
personnes pendant une longue période
dans un espace clos
cette mesure ne constitue pas une
interdiction de déplacement pour les
personnes non vaccinées assimilables aux
dispositions prises par ailleurs le
présent dispositif ne sera pas
applicable en cas d'urgence faisant
obstacle intentions du justificatifs
requis habits des favoris messieurs le
ministre est défavorable également
mathieu bouthier chat avait demandé la
parole oui juste
monsieur le président chers collègues
pour rappeler que le groupe la brume est
en marche
votre à contre cette série d'amendements
évident que sur les trajets de longue
distance qui dure un certain temps sur
un espace clos le virus peut circuler
contaminé donc il est normal que le pass
s'applique pour pour ses déplacements
je remercie je lui mentais niant à la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais saluer monsieur
rupins ce qui prouve que ce n'est pas un
problème de couleur politique mais de
bon sens et sur cette question des
déplacements de longue distance
il ya une mesure beaucoup plus simple si
vous estimez qu'être dans un tgv devient
dangereux alors pendant 18 mois vous
nous avez dit inverse avec des masques
imposer le masque ffp2 dans le tgv et ce
sera une alternative au test impossible
à faire avant de partir mais pour
conclure mon propos là dessus j'ai lu
dans libération d'hier une phrase et
j'aimerais que monsieur le ministre nous
donne des explications parce que je
pense que ce sont des journalistes
sérieux un conseiller important d'un
ministre important dit le journaliste
résume la pensée du gouvernement donc ça
va être primauté aux vacciner et vie de
merde pour les non vaccinés
voilà comment on parle dans vos cabinets
ministériels de ce que vous voulez
imposer alors on le voit bien
au fil de la discussion tout est fait
pour compliquer la vie des français pour
les emmerder comme le dit ce conseiller
mais l'objectif sanitaire n'est plus là
et on l'a vu ce matin sur la sphère de
l'extérieur on le voit aujourd'hui sur
les transports de longue distance
en vérité c'est un détournement de
procédure comme on dit en droit
administratif c'est à dire que vous
visez un objectif en prétendant défendre
la santé publique alors que vous ne
prenez pas des mesures sur les points
importants qui mériterait des actions
les frontières les soins les lic vous
continuez à supprimer et les
purificateurs d'air pour nos écoles et
nos universités à la rentrée sur le
quart sista vote électronique il a été
annoncé chacun put regagner sa place là
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
votons 153 x 1152 majorité 77 tour 67
contre 81 5
l'amendement est donc rejetée nous en
venons 658 et les défendu ben je
signerai défendu
défavorable défavorable gemini je vais
devoir qui est pour contre jeter le 47
madame ménard 40 rédactionnelle défendu
défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement mais j'ai bernalicis en
réponse oui bon je vois que ça
s'accélère sur un certain nombre d'un
moment vous nous avez vous avez un peu
accéléré le rythme juste avant et on n'a
pas pu signaler qui était l'orateur pour
l'amendement précédent monsieur le
président pas toujours on parle
aujourd'hui je sais mais c'est pour ça
que j'ai levé la main et pris la parole
pour répondre le collègue ou fiesta qui
disait voilà on est dans un
environnement clos sur une longue
distance et donc c'est normal que le
passé ni terre s'applique mais enfin si
ces salles arguments à ce moment là il
ya un problème c'est à dire que les
déplacements de longue distance souvent
couverte en tgv vont par vont souvent
plus rapides sont plus rapide qu'un ter
sur une distance plus courte où vous
êtes encore plus entassés parce qu'il
n'y a pas de contrôle des billets et
deux pays le placement est libre donc
faut savoir si ces salles arguments à ce
moment-là vous devriez dans votre propre
logique mettre le pass annie terre dans
le ter dans le rer dans le métro ont
notamment à paris etc
et donc on voit bien que ce n'est pas
votre objectif votre objectif c'est de
dope de d'inciter voire d'imposer en
fait en réalité la vaccination dans le
pays sans vouloir le dire et c'est ça
qui est dramatique c'est que on est
beaucoup à partager
c'est un objectif de vaccination delà de
la très grande majorité de la population
sauf que le moyen vous employez le plat
sanitaire créé plus de conflits de
problèmes qu'il n'en règle et en plus
par ailleurs vous dites vous même
monsieur le ministre que si on était à
100% vacciner y aurait plus de problème
or le variant delta s'il est aussi
contagieux que vous le prétendez 96% de
deux spécialisations grave éviter ça en
reste 4 % et 4 % si on a 30 % de la
population qui est qu'ils attrapent le
variant delta tout en étant vacciner ça
veut dire potentiellement 700000
hospitalisation monsieur n'ai jamais
rien à voir
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour l'adoption de l'amendement qui est
contre rejeté le 13 le 13 qui le défend
défendu le 657
madame valentin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre comment
bloquer la totalité de notre économie
qui est en pleine reprise sur lequel le
gouvernement quand même fortement
investi en rajoutant tout simplement des
fortes des contraintes fortes aux
conducteurs routiers
monsieur le ministre les conducteurs
routiers sont souvent seuls dans leur
camion et dans leur véhicule
il effectue les chargements et les
déchargements dans le strict respect des
règles sanitaires
la présentation d'un justificatif
vaccinale ou de dépistage virologique ou
de rétablissement ne concluant pas une
contamination n'apparaît donc pas
justifiée dans leur cas c'est le sens de
cet amendement merci à leur furent ces
amendements défavorable
le ministre s'est dit il est tout seul
dans sa cabine harnais je mets aux voix
ces amendements identiques défavorable
commission un gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre rejeté 289 n'est pas
défendu les 439 monsieur de cela qu'elle
soit 39 monsieur gosselin défendu
défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement je vais te vois qui est
pour contre jeter de 440 monsieur
gosselin merci monsieur le président oui
on est toujours sur cette ambiguïté dans
l'est dans les transports entre les
distances les durées et en réalité on
fait un distinguo assez subtil en
fonction du statut du transport du tgv
du ter ou de l'intercités ça ne dit pas
son nom mais ça revient vraiment à ça
donc dans le doute et sans vouloir
tomber dans une une vie administrés il
est prudent de préciser les choses
monsieur rapporteur
440 et il y à des trajets de longue
distance de courte durée et d'autres
potentiellement longues malgré leur
courte distance donc il est donc
difficile de trouver un dispositif
opérant celui prévu par le présent
dispositif me semble adapté et opérant
merci même avis mais je ministre je mets
ma vénère
une fois de plus je suis effaré
d'entendre qu'on va imposer ce pass
sanitaires à des personnes qui ont des
besoins simplement de prendre des
transports en commun pour se déplacer
parfois plusieurs fois par jour dit par
ailleurs plusieurs fois par semaine au
nom de quoi il faudrait imposer
obligatoirement cette discrimination qui
ne se justifient en rien une fois de
plus par rapport à éventuellement une
possible contamination
parce que ce variant delta dont on se
gausse depuis maintenant l'examen du
texte n'entraîne absolument aucune
hospitalisation
donc je crois que malgré le fait qu' on
essaie d'en fermer coûte que coûte et
d'empêcher les citoyens français de
vivre ceci une fois de plus c'est une
proposition complètement
disproportionnée par rapport à la
réalité de l'épidémie dans notre pays
merci gouvernement qui est pour et qui
est contre rejeté les 395 meyer à la
parole
merci monsieur le président l'amendement
395 de notre collègue il vraiment danger
pour les déplacements transports publics
de longues distances
il est nécessaire de définir plus
précisément ce qu'est un déplacement de
longue distance parce que c'est une
notion très floue
la mesure en temps et la plus évidente
compte tenu des horaires figurant sur
les billets de transport la fixation à 4
soit près d'une demi journée
correspondrait à ce que l'on peut
considérer comme une longue distance et
un élément qui est qui pourrait faire
consensus le rapporteur défavorable
monsieur le ministre monsieur jumelles
ben tout fin ce matin notre rapporteur
il essayait nous apprendre à jouer au
tennis et puis là il nous fait un sketch
de fernand raynaud hier qu'il ya des
biens des parcours l'eau qui sont
courants en temps et puis du coup et des
parcours courant tant qu'ils sont
mondiaux feront un sketch sert le sketch
à la devos de l'absurde allumé mais qui
tourne autour du rond-point 20 nous on
est en train de vous dire que il y à il
ya des gens qui prennent le tgv confort
paris lille et qu'ils seront contraints
par le pass sanitaires et puis d'autres
qui prennent des trains régionaux qui
ont été déclassés d'ailleurs des trains
intercités bondé dans une durée
équivalente à celle du paris lille et à
qui on ne donnera pas le pass sanitaires
et donc on met l'accent sur le fait que
votre critère il ya un critère à la noix
de coco
c'est un critère absurde c'est un
critère inopérant au plan sanitaire
c'est un critère c'est un vain mot c'est
indéfendable quoi donc
vous n'êtes pas bon tennis et puis en
sketches il ya plus drôle parce que
enfin cesser
alors le 395 la vie des parents que
gouvernement genevois qui est pour
contre rejeté
monsieur que cela le 443 défendu
défavorable commission gouvernement jeu
mais monsieur rufin non mais monsieur le
ministre vous êtes quand même maintenant
interpeller régulièrement sur pourquoi
le virus véhicules circulent par tgv est
pourquoi il circule pas par ter
pourquoi il va circuler peut-être par
intercités mais il circulera pas dans le
métro alors même que les conditions de
promiscuité dans le métro sont nettement
supérieurs aux as qui se passe non les
tgv donc expliquer nous quelle est la
logique quand même qu'on puisse la faire
comprendre aux administrés qu'est ce que
vous savez sur la circulation du milieu
virus quant à la circulation des
personnes
merci 443 commissaire ne manquait pour
contre rejeté
le 550 pardonnez moi je vais jouer la
parole merci monsieur le président
toujours sur cette question des
transports publics en longue distance
moi je voulais attirer l'attention et
cet amendement vise à préciser cela
attirer l'attention sur les personnes
qui sont insulaires qui habitent les
îles en particulier je pense en
particulier aux îles du ponant et dans
ma circonscription à l'île d'yeu où j'ai
été interpellé et donc on a des gens qui
font des transports du quotidien qui
vont travailler sur le sur le continent
et ça pourrait constituer un rupture
d'égalité une rupture d'égalité pardon
par rapport à celles et ceux qui qui ont
ces mêmes trajets et qui fréquentent les
tramways ou des bus donc je n'ai rien
entendu tout à l'heure dans l'est dans
les propos de monsieur le rapporteur sur
les transports maritimes et aériens
entre le continent et les et les îles
donc je voulais savoir si c'était
concernés ou pas merci beaucoup
défavorables
monsieur le ministre défavorable sur une
fin monsieur le ministre pourquoi le
virgule virus circule dans les tgv
pourquoi il circule pas dans les erreurs
pourquoi le virus circule non les
intercités et pourquoi il m'a pas
circuler dans le métro à la fin il va
quand même falloir nous donner une
explication
alors on va de molac si vous devez bien
le ministre est comme ça vous pourrez
répondre à leurs formes
oui merci monsieur le président bon si
on regarde bien la façon dont on est
dans le tgv est pendant tourner dans le
métro on a bien plus de chances
d'attraper le coronavirus dans le métro
que dans le tgv
donc si on veut interdire quelque chose
faut l'interdire faut interdire le métro
en fait je ne vois pas en plus dans le
tgv je l'avais dit en commission mais il
ya des gens qui utilisent le tgv tous
les jours parce qu'aujourd'hui tour par
exemple ou le mans sont à une heure de
paris
donc il ya des gens qui habitent là bas
qui vont travailler à paris donc ça veut
dire que ce sont des tgv du quotidien en
quelque sorte
et si je prends un autre exemple si vous
prenez rennes brest c'est dans la même
région
c'est plus long que de faire rennes
paris donc c'est ce critère là si vous
voulez est absolument obsolète enfin je
vois pas et puis si vous êtes en
première classe effectivement vous êtes
relativement loin et avec un masque donc
je ne comprends pas pourquoi finalement
ne prend pas les questions qui sont les
questions de transport plutôt que des
distances ou des durées pour vous être
agréable sur 800 et peut-être par
empathie pour les temps forts de
l'assemblée je vous répondre tout de
suite sur le la grande différence entre
le thé vert et le tgv c'est la distance
qu'on va parcourir avec le tgv c'est à
dire que le décret va prévoir
évidemment évidemment que si vous avez
bien un tgv pour faire dix minutes de
trades de transport si vous êtes entre
deux gares tgv ça ne s'appliquera pas
donc il y aura une vue d'amender
dérogation dans un cadre de concerts
ces députés on va passer des heures en
sorte de l'hémicycle et je ne lèverai
pas la voie donc je vais faire les
réponses à mon volume de voix et si vous
entendez pas vous viendrez pas me
reposer la question je répondrais une
fois donc il y aura évidemment des
discussions avec les préfets avec les
élus notamment régionaux en charge des
transports
interrégionaux pour pouvoir discuter de
la mise en place de ce là la grande
différence c'est le brassage de
population ce qu'on veut c'est que quand
vous allez passer d'une région à une
autre
vous avez toujours demandé de la
territorialité dans les mesures et on
voit qu'il y aura des taux d'incidence
qui peuvent être très élevées dans
certains départements et qui peuvent
être très faible ailleurs donc de
manière à éviter les brassages virus on
applique le passé ni terre pour les
longues distances et des l'on transporte
150 qui est pour l'adoption qui est
contre rejeté
monsieur boudou pour le 1159 son
président mais je n'ai pas entendu la
réponse de monsieur le ministre la
question que lui posait par rapport par
rapport au fait que je prends mon cas
alors peut-être que vous comprendrez un
peu mieux je viens de voyager de la
réunion vers la métropole
je ne suis vacciné d'ailleurs c'est une
question que qui me trotte j'aimerais
savoir si c'est possible parmi nous
quels sont ceux qui sont vaccinées
[Rires]
donc donc
donc je suis vacciné j'ai mes deux doses
mais il paraît qu il faudrait peut-être
une troisième dose reconnais cieux de
rien alors je suis sérieux monsieur le
ministre pour repartir
je viens de recevoir un mail de ma
compagnie d' qui me dit ma il faut un
test pc ou antigénique
alors
bus ne circule pas dans le sens réunion
paris mais dans le sens paris réunion
qui chacune j'aimerais savoir soit on
fait confiance au vaccin soit on ne fait
pas confiance au vaccin
l'acide la réponse me suis dit monsieur
les reporter cet amendement oui merci
monsieur président seul le schéma
vaccinal complet permet une protection
optimale face à la cohue vide nous
parlons de territoires qui sont soit
particulièrement vulnérables face à
l'épidémie et qu'il convient de protéger
soi de territoire où l'épidémie circule
activement ou l'état d'urgence sanitaire
est déclaré et je pense que la réunion
en fait partie avis défavorable monsieur
le ministre
défavorable monsieur le président
mélenchon oui je je souscris tout à fait
à cet amendement qui souligne une
aberration mais il faut pas trop en
vouloir au ministre la décision prise
était aberrante
les conclusions ne peuvent pas être
différente tout sera l'invraisemblable
donc si nous sommes dans un tgv pour
moins de 10 minutes
eh bien nous n'avons pas besoin ne pas
sanitaire c'est simple à comprendre mais
si c'est plus 6 alors donc il y aura un
contrôle qui portera non plus seulement
sur l'identité le pass annie terre mais
la distance donc entre deux gars qui
seraient rapprochés il y aura un
contrôle de tous les billets de manière
à vérifier ce qu'ils sont là pour la
longue distance et pour la courte
distance
les agents de la sncf vont être ravis
d'apprendre que leur nom va être
multipliée pour opérer ces contrôles
j'ajoute que
nous devrions étudier la possibilité de
fournir aux virus un marquage qui lui
permet lorsqu'il monte dans un rer de
rester hors contrôle mais lorsque le rer
lui-même se transforme en ter comme
c'est le cas dans la direction du loiret
ou comme c'est le cas dans la direction
de l'aéroport orangis à ce moment là le
pass navigo qui normalement a dit qu une
zone du rer se transforme en une
exigence de passe à dix terre donc il
faut vérifier tout le monde à partir de
enfin ça tient pas d'où vous venez de
dire vous même que ça dépendait de la
distance parce que vous êtes un être
rationnel
donc vous voyez bien que ça n'a pas de
sens de contrôler si non mais avec ce
que vous nous proposez ce n'est pas la
société du contrôle permanent ça c'est
n'importe quand qu'il faudra contrôler
c'est la pagaille
la chienlit le désordre l'épuisement de
tout le monde dans des contrôles qui
montrent aucun sens et qui provoqueront
partout des conflits tels que sont les
français aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
si monsieur le président je voudrais
rebondir sur les propos de mon collègue
poudre hooks je viens de la réunion un
territoire où l'épidémie flambe où on
questionne le retour donc du couvre-feu
du confinement également et enfin il ya
déjà un couvre-feu à 23 heures n'ont pas
d'avancée et pour partir de la réunion
comme je suis vacciné je n'ai eu à faire
aucun test pcr
par contre pour y revenir
alors que le virus circule quand même
moi largement ici je devrais faire mon
test pcr pour rentrer à la réunion où
est la logique monsieur le ministre
où est la logique s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
d'abord il ya deux éléments de réponse
pour ce qui concerne la réunion ça
faisait pardon partie d'une réflexion
interministérielle avec les avis
scientifiques pour éviter d'envoyer
d'amener dans des territoires fragiles
des variants qu'ils pouvaient y causer
des vagues épidémiques et ensuite vous
savez très bien que ces critères sont
réévalués en fonction des situations
épidémiques propres à chaque territoire
ce que vous décrivez n'est pas amené à
rester dans la durée sur la question
pour répondre à monsieur mélenchon
présent mélenchon s'il veut bien
peut-être que je lui réponde ce
mélenchon
je vais sans doute pas été assez claire
l'intention du gouvernement dans la loi
c'est de permettre de prévoir lusage
impasse sanitaires pour certains types
de longs déplacements
quels qu'en soient d'ailleurs le vecteur
de déplacement vous poser la question de
savoir si comment est ce qu'on va faire
la différence entre des petits
déplacements sur des longues lignes et
les longs déplacements sur les mêmes
lignes et c'est là que je vous ai dit
qu'il y à des situations propres à
chaque territoire qui appelle avoir une
réflexion territoriale en ni avec les
élus les préfet en concertation de
manière à trouver les dispositifs qui ne
soit pas aussi absurde que ce que vous
décrivez par anticipation monsieur
mélenchon donc je le redis le principe
c'est d'éviter les brassages de
populations là où nous avions interdit
les déplacements interrégionaux pendant
les périodes de confinement pour éviter
les brassages nous ne voulons plus
interdire les déplacements
interrégionaux et je suis sûr que vous
dites vous que vous êtes favorables à
cette hypothèse est donc de la même
manière que caen ne voulons pas fermer
les restaurants nous prévoyons d'y
installer des passes sanitaires comme
nous ne voulons pas interdire
déplacement interrégionaux nous
prévoyons un dispositif de passes
sanitaire qui permettra aux gens de
continuer à circuler les conditions
opérationnelles vous avez raison de dire
que c'est une question importante mais
vous êtes législateur depuis bien plus
longtemps que moi et vous savez que cela
renvoie à un décret et que ce décret
précisera toutes les données donc là
nous actons le principe de pouvoir si la
situation le nécessitait avoir recours
aux pas sali taire plutôt que de
supprimer les déplacements
interrégionaux
notre avis défavorable de la commission
du gouvernement qu'est ce qui est pour
qu'est ce qui est contre rejeté
monsieur benassaya pour le 928 oui merci
monsieur le président on va essayer de
rester sur la question des transports
malgré l'absurdité de ce qu'on entend
depuis un moment
il me semble quand même que le port du
masque ffp2 est largement suffisant
largement suffisant pour limiter toute
transmission du virus d'une porte tort à
une personne saine
le masque ffp2 protège sur des
transmissions et des contaminations
pendant une durée d'environ huit heures
et filtres presque intégralement les
particules il est donc parfaitement
sécurisé et sécurisant
aussi il est inutile de restreindre la
libre circulation des personnes à la
condition d'un pass sanitaire que
j'estime totalement absurde
cet amendement vise à remplacer donc
l'obligation du pass sanitaires pour les
transports de longue durée et à le
remplacer par le port du masque ffp2 je
vous remercie
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
cet amendement est tellement évident au
point d'ailleurs que madame merkel en
allemagne très tôt à distribuer à toute
la population âgée des masques ffp2 pour
les protéger au moment des recrues
descente de deux de l'épidémie et donc
je ne vois pas pourquoi nous ne
pourrions pas adopter cet amendement de
pur bon sens enfin vous parliez de
brassage moi monsieur le ministre je
vous emmène sur la ligne rer d qui mène
à ma ville de yerres dans l'essonne
s'il n'y a pas de brassage à la gare de
châtelet
s'il n'y a pas de brassage à paris-nord
s'il n'y a pas de brassage dans les rer
alors expliquez moi ce qui se passe dans
une région de 12 millions d'habitants
je pense qu'il ya un peu plus de
brassage en ile de france que dans un
tgv où il ya les conditions d' espace
donc ce terme du brassage n'a aucun sens
et défie toute rationalité vraiment vous
ne pouvez pas à ce point vous moquer des
français
merci
non mais c'est bien on on a eu du
ministre qui l'a on a l'impression que
les ministères parviennent de donner des
ordres virus en disant que le virus est
pas capable de prendre un pass navigo
mais en revanche il sera capable de
réserver son billet pour prendre le tgv
comment vous voulez que les gens aient
confiance en vous comment voulez que les
gens aient confiance dans votre science
quand sa valeur apparaître comme une
absolue absurdité que évidemment dans un
métro qui est bondé il ya bien des
chances que le virus circule au moins
autant que dans un tgv
là vous avancez un autre motif vous dise
c'est pour pas que le virus circule
d'une région à l'autre
mais à aucun moment dans la discussion
vous n'avez prévu de une insularité du
virus est-ce que là vous allez faire des
contrôles lors des départs en vacances
aux aires d'autoroute pour dire les
personnes qui sont testées positives ils
n'ont pas le droit de passer d'une d'une
région à l'autre
vous n'avez absolument aucune stratégie
pour dire de rabattre le coc vite sur
des zones vous le laisser circuler de
manière générale et vous dites sap dans
le tgv
là ils risquent de circuler ce que ça
démontre c'est votre absence de
cohérence
votre absence de stratégie quand on ne
fait pas de contrôle et moi je suis pas
pourra pas de sanitaires du tout mais
quand on en fait pas dans le métro mais
quand encore je suis en enfer dans le
tgv c'est juste l'elysée qui donne des
ordres aux virus à peut pas se passer
comme ça et les gens le savent et les
gens le sentent donc je vais devoir
l'influent 28 qui est pour 928 quand
rejeté le 140 monsieur gosselin oui nous
allons quitter les trains mais si
j'ajouterai peut-être pour pour un sujet
grave
cette conclusion d'un sketch bien connu
pour ceux qui prennent le train c'est
vous qui voyez
mais ils ont eu des problèmes mais je
crois qu'effectivement nos concitoyens
auront il y en a qui ont essayé ils vont
avoir bien des problèmes
alors ils vont avoir bien des problèmes
aussi pour aller dans les centres
commerciaux c'est l'objet de cette
discussion d'amendements
en commun ou discussion commune
d'amendements qui tourne autour des ces
centres commerciaux les passes sanitaire
ne doivent pas concerner des actes du
quotidien aller dans un centre
commercial même d'une certaine surface
et je parle pas de grandes surfaces en
tant que tel c'est parfois un acte du
quotidien bien sûr pour pouvoir faire
ses courses nourrir mais dans un certain
nombre de quartiers c'est parfois là la
pharmacie du coin qui se trouve à
l'intérieur du centre commercial donc
soumettre à une obligation de passe les
centres commerciaux c'est vraiment
attentes et à l'élémentaire du du
quotidien et nous voulons absolument
l'éviter
alors on nous dit ne vous inquiétez pas
dans un certain nombre de cases ce sont
les préfets qui pourront apprécier la
situation en fonction du bassin de vie
du bassin d'emploi etc
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir une rupture
d'égalité entre certains bassins qui
seront plus ou moins reconnus comme
rentrant dedans d'autres qui n'y seront
pas dans des départements voisins et
tous les gestionnaires insiste sur le
caractère ingérable ingérable de l'accès
à ses cendres et donc nous voulons les
retirer merci l'assemblée que sur le 140
est identique à la demande du groupe
l'est républicain il y aura un scrutin
public de scrutin est annoncée dans
l'instinct de l'assemblée le 402 c'est
le même il est défendu on est d'accord
le 624 c'est le même
merci effectivement nous opposons à
l'élargissement du pasa knitter pour les
grands magasins et centres commerciaux
suite à l'avis du conseiller d'état sauf
erreur le texte a été amendé et dans le
texte aujourd'hui il ya une exception à
la présentation du pass and i ter
lorsqu'aucun autre établissement
commercial permettant l'acquisition de
biens alimentaires ou mettez co de
première nécessité mais accessibles à
proximité
donc monsieur le ministre je voudrais
savoir comment concrètement vous allez
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre cette exception
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par le terme de proximité qui va faire
les contrôles et dans quelle mesure ils
vont pouvoir s'exercer par exemple sur
des personnes qui sont en vacances qui
voyaient dans un centre commercial comme
on va pouvoir savoir d'où ils viennent
pourquoi il n'y a pas de centre à
proximité autre que celui là etc
merci
si le fils en 68 et défendu le 678
défendu le 720 défendu le 741 défendu le
678 monsieur le furent vous m'avez raté
j'ai bien regardé pourtant un mais vous
donne la parole à lévis merci monsieur
le président oui je souhaite intervenir
pour défendre cet amendement en
comprenant bien évidemment la nécessité
du pass sanitaire mais vous alerter
monsieur le ministre sur les grandes
inquiétudes qui ont été exprimées par
les centres commerciaux d'une surface de
plus de 20 mille mètres carrés il y a eu
une avancée en commission qui est
significative vous laisser la main aux
préfets de département pour juger de
l'opportunité ou non de mettre en place
le pass sanitaire mais vraiment cessé
ses centres commerciaux ont subi de
plein fouet pendant de nombreux mois la
fermeture de leur établissement ils nous
alertent sur les difficultés qu'ils vont
rencontrer avec des files d'attentes
pour le contrôle du pass sanitaire qui
va les contraindre à embaucher du
personnel supplémentaire et à un moment
où leur modèle économique a été mis la
mamie mis à mal par ailleurs ils nous
alertent aussi sur le côté discriminant
à la fois pour les commerces qui sont
situés dans ses centres commerciaux mais
aussi pour les salariés qui travaillent
donc c'est vraiment vous sensibilisez
essayer de trouver un terrain d'entente
d'entente qui permettent de prendre en
compte ces difficultés je vous remercie
si donc
j'avais passé les autres monsieur rues
places et est donc défendue 800 monsieur
poterie mais je peux très d'abord merci
monsieur le président le conseil d'état
s'est prononcé contre cette disposition
il souligne que les études scientifiques
à notre disposition montrent que les
centres commerciaux sont des lieux sûrs
et qu'en plus cette obligation créerait
des inégalités inégalités pour les
commerçants pour les salariés et pour
les clients une inégalité pour les
clients parce que cette mesure
comprennent mais qu'on promet l'accès
aux produits de première nécessité pour
répondre à cette inégalité relevé par le
conseil d'état vous avez proposé une
solution lors de l'examen en commission
mais elle me paraît inapplicable ce qui
est prévu dans le texte c'est que le
préfet puisse autoriser l'accès aux
centres commerciaux sans pass sanitaires
pour l'achat de produits de première
nécessité en fonction de l'offre
commerciale sur le bassin de vie
mais concrètement comment ça se passe
monsieur le ministre sur quels critères
je pense que nous sommes en train de
créer une usine à gaz en autorisant
certains centres commerciaux et pas
d'autres sur décrypter des critères qui
feront l'objet de litiges c'est un
moment propose aussi un autre problème
d'une équité entre les salariés du
secteur du commerce qui n'est pas non
plus résolus par l'amendement de la
commission
prenez les entreprises qui ont plusieurs
points de vente comment expliquer aux
salariés de ceux qui travaillent dans le
centre commercial devront se faire
vacciner et pas les autres
le dernier problème de cet alinéa c'est
la distorsion de concurrence pour les
commerçants avec un détournement de
clientèle et avec en plus des risques de
contraventions pour des faits qu'ils ne
sont pas responsables
chers collègues je partage la volonté de
prendre des mesures fortes pour faire
face à la crise mais il me semble
nécessaire de supprimer cet alinéa parce
qu'il est inefficace inapplicable et
disproportionnée merci alors madame
ménard de si monsieur le président en
fait on est toujours avec le même
problème de lisibilité de la loi comme
je l' ai déjà dit moi je suis pas opposé
au pass sanitaires on est simplement il
faut que les règles soient claires il
faut que les règles soient claires et
qui tablent entre tous c'est le conseil
d'état qui est mais je peux très bien me
le rappelait si le conseil d'état lui
même qui dans son avis
rendus sur le présent projet de loi a
précisé que les données épidémiologiques
et les avis scientifiques ne font pas
apparaître au regard des mesures
sanitaires déjà applicable et en
particulier des existants des exigences
qui s'attache au respect des gestes
barrières un intérêt significatif de
cette mesure pour le contrôle de
l'épidémie
alors pourquoi dans ce cas là réduire
drastiquement l'activité de certains
commerçants sous le seul prétexte que
leur boutique se situe dans un centre
commercial
ils ont déjà subi ces commerçants
plusieurs fermetures extrêmement
pénalisante pour leurs activités et ils
ont subi de très lourdes pertes
et puis ça c'est pas moi qui le dit ce
sont les statistiques les centres
commerciaux de plus de 20 mille mètres
carrés comme ça a été envisagé un moment
donné ça ne représente que 5 % des
commerces et on peut donc légitimement
s'interroger sur l'utilité de cette
mesure
quand rien n'est prévu on vient de
l'évoquer dans les transports publics
par exemple dans le métro et est
vraiment c'est une question encore une
fois de lisibilité il faut que les
règles puissent s'appliquer de la même
façon à tous et pas faire de dérogation
dans tous les sens je remercie dani mais
merci monsieur le président non
simplement mais c'est le même 1 c'est le
même amendement que mes collègues un
certain nombre d'arguments auquel je
m'associe ont déjà été défendue mais je
ne vois pas ce que dans un endroit on
applique déjà des mesures barrières où
nos commerçants ont déjà fait des
efforts pour tout mettre en place depuis
des années depuis des mois et des
semaines ont subi des fermetures je ne
sais pas en termes de santé publique ce
que le pass annie terre va faire de plus
vous irez faut restreindre la liberté de
choix pour une personne d'aller faire
ses courses dans un centre commercial ou
un autre me paraît engendrer un risque d
nick était d' inégalités sociales et
territoriales et donc me paraît
disproportionnée
c'est pour ça que je souhaite supprimer
cet alinéa monsieur nous mêmes
défendue vous avez la parole si monsieur
le président oui cette disposition
prévoit subordonnés l'accès aux grands
magasins et centres commerciaux impasse
sanitaire au delà d'un seuil défini par
décret alors pourquoi tel seuil plutôt
qu'un autre
cela me rappelle l'ouverture des centres
commerciaux que vous avez autorisé
pendant que les librairies restés fermés
je ne doute pas que le conseil
constitutionnel examinera la proportion
de la proportionnalité d'un tel seuil
par rapport à l'objectif poursuivi
aussi il serait opportun que ce seuil
soit défini au terme d'un débat clair
pour toutes les parties prenantes
il ne s'agit pas pour accéder à un acte
essentiel de la vie quotidienne de
donner blanc seing au gouvernement alors
pour continuer par rapport à tout à
l'heure je disais que en fonction du
nombre de voyages que j'aurais entre
paris et la réunion
on va me mettre dans le nez à peu près
60 fois deux cotons tiges ça peut faire
des dégâts
donc avant de passer la valeur à porter
je préside quand même pour
l'organisation de travaux une ou deux
choses un moment d'attention mais chaque
collecte si vous le voulez bien
depuis la reprise d'une travaux ce matin
à 9 heures nous sommes un rythme de 40
amendements examinés à l'heure très
concrètement il nous reste 728
amendements examinés à ce rythme là il
faut chacun en conviendra 18 heures
c'est à dire qu'en prenant l'hypothèse
que nous ne faisons aucune pause cette
nuit aucune pause et demi on travaille
toute la nuit nous n'aurons pas achever
nos travaux avant demain 13h donc que
chacun mesure tout ça hein je le dis au
président de grupo à ceux qui en font fi
cependant nos travaux
c'était vraiment à intégrer monsieur
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
le présent dispositif s'appliquera au
delà d'un certain seuil défini par
décret le gouvernement ayant annoncé
qu'ils retiraient le seuil de 20 mille
mètres carrés qui a prévalu d'ailleurs
pendant le confinement ce qui
intéressera donc 400 soit la moitié de
ce qui existe en commission mardi
nous avons adopté un amendement de notre
collègue thomas rudigoz permettons au
préfet d'autoriser l'accès sans pass
sanitaire au centre établissements
commerciaux comportant des points de
vente de biens et première nécessité et
leur qu'aucun autre établissement
commercial n'est accessible à proximité
l'ajout de cette disposition me semble
permettre de surmonter définitivement
l'avis défavorable
le conseil d'état ayant vendu sur cette
présente disposition donc c'est l'avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie donc
nous allons procéder au vote
140 est identique chacun put regagner sa
place
c'est bon le scrutin le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants soit 2,15
exprimé 72 majorité 87% à 14 contre 98
l'amendement n'est donc pas adoptée le 3
131 qui le défend malin florennes
défendu défavorable commission
gouvernement je vais te vois qui pour
contre jeté ma la meynard le 48
si monsieur le président c'est un
amendement de repli
parce que si le seuil de 20 mille mètres
carrés devait être retenue il serait
quand même fort utile que le préfet en
concertation avec le maire de la ville
du centre commercial concernées puissent
établir des dérogations en fonction
notamment de la configuration des lieux
parce que vous avez tous les centres
commerciaux ne me semble pas je vous
remercie ouest 181,8 monsieur gosselin
défendu monsieur bérulle 418 défendu
monsieur terry 1096 défendu je vais
m'essayer à 929 défendu défavorable
commission gouvernement je me revois qui
est pour compte
rejetée mais j'ai dit filippo défendu
défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement je le vois qui est pour
contre je t'ai madame d'eau défendu
merci merci monsieur le président c'est
un mouvement propose que la présentation
d' appât sanitaire valide à l'entrée
d'un grand magasin où la sens commercial
soit suffisant pour ce que les librement
dans son enceinte
l'objectif est d'éviter des
attroupements dans un lieu confiné en
multipliant les queues devant différents
magasins qu'opposant ces entités
de plus les pieds ce procédé peut créer
des craquements conséquent aux entrées
il paraît plus raisonnable s'est
littéralement parlant de conti la foule
à l'extérieur
je remercie défavorable commission
défavorable gouvernement je mets deux
voies qui est pour contre je t'ai
discussion commune
le 831 merci monsieur le président mais
moi je suis tout à fait comme nombre de
mes collègues favorables aux pass
sanitaires cela dit je pense que nous ne
pouvons pas demander à nos concitoyens
des choses que nous ne nous
appliquerions pas en premier lieu à nous
mêmes en 2017 nombre d'entre nous avons
été élus en n'ayant chevillée au corps
la volonté d'exemplarité et donc
montrons l'exemplarité en faisant en
sorte que l'accès à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat aux conseils
départementaux conseils régionaux et
ainsi de suite soit soumis à un pass
annie terre il y à aussi nombre de gens
qui travaillent dans ces instances et
qui ont besoin d'être protégés et nous
élus rencontre ont énormément de monde
donc
obligeons nouveau pas sanitaires pour
venir siéger dans ces instances voilà
donc les autres d'amendements la
situation commune et sous-amendement ne
sont pas défendus sur un porteur
défavorable chez ministre défavorable
vous avez là parce que ce point là on
s'est très vite qui peut être interprété
surinterpréter l'interpréter la question
n'est pas de savoir si on est favorable
ou si je suis favorable ou non dans
l'absolu ça ne me choque pas la question
de savoir si c'est constitutionnel ou
pas et là il ya une grande difficulté
c'est que nul ne peut empêcher par
exemple des parlementaires de voter un
budget c'est le fondement même de cette
fameuse immunité parlementaire qui fait
qu'on ne peut pas vous empêcher d'aller
dans un hémicycle pour voter votre
budget donc le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité est un est élevé
donc c'est pour cette raison que le
gouvernement est défavorable de ma de
manière à maintenir l'intégrité du texte
dans des décisions précédentes le
conseil constitue à relever que les
chambres parlementaires était exclu et
le voyez plutôt d'un bon oeil dans la
mesure où et ça pouvait être considérée
comme une censure démocratique s'il y
avait impossibilité pour des
parlementaires d'aller voter un budget
c'est pour ces raisons là encore une
fois que le sujet est très très sensible
et très punchy que je me préférait
prendre la parole merci il m'arrivait le
12 mai tu jolivet
merci monsieur le président on me
donnait la parole ça me permettra d'agir
par rapport à ma famille et aux propos
de monsieur ministre sur la notion
d'anti consignés dans
anticonstitutionnalité je ne sais pas
même si j'ai vu des communiqués de la fp
aujourd'hui du président d'assemblée
nationale qui était différent entre
celui d'hier et celui d'aujourd'hui pour
autant l'amendement que j'ai proposé
mois vise à rendre possible rendre
possible pour tous ceux qui détiennent
une autorité publique de pouvoir au cas
par cas y compris des mers d'ailleurs au
cas par cas d'exiger des spas sanitaires
pour pouvoir permettre l'accès à
certains bâtiments publics en fonction
du degré de la circulation du virus est
sans doute du nombre de personnes qui
sont à l'intérieur
ça c'est la 1ère partie la deuxième
partie sur l'exemplarité sur rejoindre
et ma collègue le bodo à cubières parce
qu'en fait aujourd'hui si l'un d'entre
nous était atteint du virus ebola
quand j'entends monsieur le ministre
c'est vrai dire qu'on ne pourrait pas
lui demander ne pas venir je m'inquiète
un peu et j'ai le sentiment que si on
rend possible par le règlement intérieur
on doit pouvoir permettre à tous les
détenteurs de l'autorité publique
au titre des mesures d'ordre intérieur
qui est une qui est un domaine très
connu dans le domaine administratif ne
permette à tout détenteur de l'autorité
publique de proposer des mesures dans 22
mesures dans un intérieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
la représentation nationale
la représentation du peuple au calme
certains d'entre nous veulent appliquer
un patch sanitaires de manière globale
généralisée je crois qu'il ne peut pas
être compréhensible pour nos concitoyens
et nos concitoyens d'imposer des règles
pour eux que nous appliquerions pas à
nous mêmes j'entends le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
mes chers collègues mais il ne faut pas
prendre le conseil constitutionnel et
cette décision comme une punition
ils vérifient simplement en bon
ordonnancement entre les lois que nous
adoptons
ici et le respect de la constitution cyr
certaines dispositions doivent être
censuré don't hate moi je crois qu'il y
en a plusieurs qui ont été adoptées
jusqu'à maintenant dans différents
textes mais au singulier rement dans
celui ci qui ont été censurées par le
conseil constitutionnel ou qui vont
l'être
en revanche je crois qu'il est important
d'affirmer la volonté de la
représentation nationale de se
considérer comme un ensemble faisant
corps avec l'ensemble de la population
française répondant aux mêmes règles
merci donc le ministre a répondu ainsi
que le rapporteur je vais mettre ouvrez
cet amendement aucun des
sous-amendements n'étant défendu le 831
qui et pour qui est content rejeté le 12
pieds pour contre rejeté et le le
dernier le 553 qui est pour
on est rejeté
alors monsieur ruffat la parole pour lui
805 882
1 un article vient de tomber la du monde
qui nous dit cinq millions de personnes
à risque toujours pas vaccinées avec
plein de facteurs de comores d'humilité
dialyse chroniques diabète maladies
respiratoires et qui ajoute chez les
plus de 65 ans deux millions de
personnes n'ont reçu aucune dose c'est
ça qui devrait être le coeur de notre
débat cet après midi et ces jours ci ça
devrait être comment on va faire pour
aller chercher les plus fragiles comment
on va faire alors que la france est
aujourd'hui le dernier pays d'europe de
l'ouest
le dernier quant à la vaccination des
personnes fragiles si c'est même un avis
publié ces mêmes dans le rapport du
conseil scientifique qui dit qu'on est
les 15e au total dans l'europe
on n'est pas bon là dessus on devrait se
demander comment on va faire pour aller
chercher ça devrait être le coeur de la
discussion plutôt que se demander si ça
si si on interdit en tgv si on interdit
les gentils heures où est ce qu'on va
mettre le passé ni terre dans les
centres commerciaux chez le coiffeur ou
pas
quels sont les relais qui sont possibles
voilà l'interrogation en angleterre
c'est le national health service qui a
envoyé un mail à tout le monde pour des
convocations pour demander aux personnes
âgées aux personnes à risque de venir
discuter de la vaccination
c'est un historien qui m'a formé de ça
ce matin mais je rencontrais un un
caméraman de télé qui me disait ma voix
la dent dans ma mairie à s'amender
ma mère a été convoqué enfin invité par
la mairie allait discuter de la
vaccination mais et j'entends que ça a
été mené dans certains hameaux de
communes mais c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui était 6 matile systématiser
les médecins traitants qui sont laissés
comme étant un point peu important du
dispositif auquel on préfère les bus
vaccinodromes et enfin on devrait avoir
mais multiplié démultiplier des brigades
mobiles qui est pour mission d'aller
chercher d'aller rencontrer les
personnes qui sont à risque et d'aller
les ramener
vers un outil qui est la vaccination
ce sont des brigades qui existe dans
d'autres pays d'europe
là il ya un certain non c'est de ça dont
on devrait discuter de manière centrale
aujourd'hui comment on ramène ses sept
millions de personnes vers mais une un
début de solution merci est ce qu'on
peut considérer que jusqu au 1130 vous
les avez défendu c'est la même logique
c'est pour ça que les assauts lui c'est
une possibilité monsieur président ça
dépendra la discussion avec le ministre
monsieur prison alors ça dépend de vous
messieurs monsieur le rapporteur
merci pour ce qui pousse le président a
parlé vous devez répondre aussi pour
répondre jusqu'au 1130 et la même
logique les ans fragile
alors donc il me semble en premier lieu
disproportionné de demander au premier
ministre de s'ingérer dans le
fonctionnement de brigade mise en place
par chacune des cpm de temps que votre
des la dénomination brigade qu'ovide
n'existe pas par dans la loi par
ailleurs ces missions sont par ailleurs
remplies par d'autres acteurs comme un
médiateur de l'ue tant qu'éco vite
déployé par les ars sur le terrain et
ils s'attachent à convaincre les
personnes de l'intérêt de se faire
vacciner dans des territoires où la
vaccination est encore plus répandues
comme l'est de la région parisienne
de ce point de vue là votre amendement
me semble satisfait sans qu'il soit
besoin d'imposer aux brigades une unique
mission au détriment de l'ensemble des
tâches qu'elles accomplissent par
ailleurs donc c'est un avis
favorable défavorable
monsieur le ministre
monsieur rufin j'ai attendu longtemps
longtemps le moment de vous dire que je
suis d'accord avec vous non pas sur
l'amendement rassurez vous mais quand
vous dites que l'urgence pour notre pays
c'est de vacciner les plus fragiles
vacciner celles et ceux qui sont encore
âgés vaccinés celles et ceux qui sont
porteuses de mag qui sont porteurs de
maladies vous avez cité le bon chiffre
il reste 5 millions de personnes qui par
leur âge ou leur état de santé n'ont pas
encore été vaccinés
or ce sont 5 millions de personnes
particulièrement exposées au risque de
formes graves
donc je vous rejoins monsieur rufin sur
l'objectif de votre amendement et même
s'ils ont eu toute une partie de votre
discours en vous écoutant je vois que
vous êtes en revanche pas suffisamment
bien informé j'en suis désolé peut-être
que nous n'avons pas suffisamment
communiqué je vais donc profiter de ce
moment pour vous pour vous dire ce que
nous faisons déjà et vous verrez qu'on
va au delà de votre amendement vous avez
parlé de du nhs en angleterre qui
envoient des mails
c'est formidable d'envoyer des mails et
c'est important de le faire on envoyer
des millions des courriers c'est
formidable on envoyer des millions et un
truc qu'on fait qu'ils ne font pas c'est
qu'on appelle les gens chez eux on les
appelle
monsieur député rufin j'étais avec le
président de la république dans une
centrale de l'assurance maladie où il y
avait là dans un open space l'équivalent
de 80 peut-être 80 jeunes qui avaient
été recrutés ça tombe bien parce qu'on
leur a donné d'ailleurs un emploi et
certains seront amenés à rester en cdi
qui sont formés et qu'ils appellent un
an une à une toutes les personnes qui
sont sur la liste des personnes fragiles
non vaccinés qui les appelle chez elle
lorsqu'ils n'arrivent pas à les joindre
leur envoie un texto lorsqu'elles ont un
portable sinon les rappels dans le sms
monsieur enfin vous j'ai pas
l'impression que mes coutier et après
vous allez représenter de tous les
amendements
d'accord d'accord d'accord vous êtes
très fort vous avez dans le même sms
qu'on envoie à ces personnes mais c'est
un compliment je vous ferai plus de
compliments je vous jure
c'était le dernier dans les sms qu'on
envoie à ces personnes on leur indique
aussi du numéro coupe-file qui depuis
des mois permet à ces personnes d'avoir
un accès prioritaire et sans délai à
toute solution pouvant les vaccinés à
toute solution on a passé un million et
demi
tu appelles et ne croyez pas que c'est
un appel bonjour on vous appelle de
l'assurance maladie pour faire vacciner
et non les personnes prennent le temps
de discuter
j'ai assisté à des appels qui duré 20
minutes parce que il y avait une dame
qui était âgé vous allez aimer ça j'ai
même dû trouver un prénom comme vous
monsieur rufine s'appelait marcel elle a
83 ans et son mari étaient à l'hôpital
était toute seule elle avait peur de se
faire vacciner
il a fallu du temps de conviction pour
lui dire voilà le vaccin vous protège le
vaccin vous éviter la forme grave
si vous voulez on peut vous envoyer une
ambulance chez vous un taxi on le prend
en charge
on vous amène au centre vous avez un
rendez vous si vous préférez le matin ou
l'après midi c'est vraiment du travail à
façon du travail humain en contact
direct je pense que c'est mieux qu'un
mail et qu'un courrier encore l'autre
chose qui est fait
vous avez dit il faudrait que les
médecins il faudrait que les médecins
soient investis de la mission d'appeler
leurs patients quand ils sont pas
vaccinés ça tombe très bien monsieur
rufin parce qu il a fallu trois ou
quatre semaines pour qu'on l'ait mais
comme on a eu enfin d'accord de la cnil
parce que figurez-vous qu'il fallait
l'accord de la cnil pour pouvoir envoyer
aux médecins traitants la liste de leurs
patients qu'ils suivent au quotidien
qu'il n'avait pas encore été vaccinés
nous avons envoyé donc des emails pour
le coup sur les canaux habituels à tous
les médecins traitants de ce pays avec
la liste exhaustive de tous leurs
patients pas encore vaccinés
des médecins les appels j'ai fait une
visioconférence avec plusieurs milliers
de pharmacien tout à l'heure en leur
demandant de se mettre en lien avec les
médecins parce qu'on ne peut pas donner
de cette liste au pharmacien parce que
sinon on n'aurait pas l'accord des
autorités voyez qu'on a un état très
protecteur quand même qu'on a beaucoup
de règles et de normes et je sais que
vous êtes sensibles et les pharmaciens
peuvent désormais demander peuvent
proposer pourquoi pas aux médecins de
leur filer un coup de main parce qu'ils
peuvent aussi des vaccinés et on ne
s'arrête pas là monsieur rufin ont fait
aussi appel à quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien en société et auquel
vous êtes sensibles ces deux le tissu
associatif
plus de 900 associations sont mobilisées
à nos côtés dans cette campagne
vaccinale dans les communes en ruralité
ainsi que les crs
j'ai reçu personnellement et plusieurs
fois l'ensemble de l'association des
ccas des responsables associatifs de ce
pays qui sont mobilisés pour aller
sensibiliser il ya des médiateurs en
santé notamment dans les quartiers
populaires et donc s'installer aussi des
centres de vaccination dans les centres
commerciaux où il ya aussi la des
médiateurs issus des quartiers
populaires vacciner eux-mêmes et qu'il
est de sensibiliser les personnes tant
qu'ils viennent se faire vacciner
je crois pas qu'on ait besoin d'avoir un
amendement dans la loi qui nous donne
cette injonction monsieur le rufin on le
fait on le fait depuis des mois on ne
fait on ne fera peut-être sans doute
jamais assez tant qu'on n'aura pas
atteint les 100%
aidez-nous aidez-nous mais pas par la
loi par l'injonction aider les
associations allée les voir dans votre
circonscription demandez leur comment
vous pouvez démobilisé comme nous le
faisons et la majorité or cela aussi
très mobilisés donc un avis défavorable
sur le centre de saint amand nord vous
aurez compris les raisons je ne
répondrai plus sur les autres évidemment
alors donc de deux orateurs monsieur
rufin j'ai de la verpillière monsieur
prix mais je d'éprouver flandre et tous
les amendements aussi donc le second
non mais là on examine les les halles
les amendements jusqu'au ya pas de
raison monsieur peillon je vais défendre
à paris j'en ai trois
si on permet pas monsieur le président
qui ait une discussion qu'ils soient
larges sur un point qui me paraît clé
est que éventuellement différents
orateurs de groupe puisse s'exprimer
jeux jeux j'en viendrais on a même
refusé les personnes 13 villes et
permettez
à différents orateurs de groupe c'est un
point clé pour moi de la discussion
monsieur le président défend des sur le
fond je réfléchis dépend donc c'est si
je défends donc strictement le 882 là
monsieur le président si d'abord je peux
vous donner des tas de témoignages et je
vous me priverais de livrer les prénoms
de gens qui sont en situation de diabète
de maladies chroniques et ainsi de suite
qu'ils n'ont pas eu de contact pour
qu'on leur propose la vaccination pour
qu'on leur dise à quel point dans leur
situation
il ya un bénéfice qui sera infiniment
supérieurs aux risques
c'est la première chose ensuite comment
ça se fait si vous avez déployé tous ses
moyens qu'on ait des résultats qui soit
aussi mauvais la france donc 15 yens
pays de l'union européenne dernier pays
de l'europe de l'ouest avec 80 % des
plus de 80 ans vaccinés alors que le
danemark est à 100%
l'irlande est à 100% la norvège est à
100%
le portugal est à 100% l'espagne est à
la suède est à 95% l'italie est à 93% et
je pense que c'est pas seulement par la
loire monsieur le ministre c'est par le
fait le par exemple venir ici en nous
demandant en organisant des débats et en
lui demandant comment on va faire quels
sont les rôles et qu'on peut trouver
pour aller chercher ces personnes plutôt
que de passer par rapport au tour il
avait recueilli hier la parole
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président sans rentrer
dans la dans la discussion sur tel ou
tel article moi je voudrais porter
témoignage qu'effectivement et là je
suis d'accord avec monsieur rufin et
avec monsieur le ministre
effectivement le sujet c'est de faire en
sorte que toutes les personnes
vulnérables les personnes à risque
particulièrement les personnes âgées qui
ne sont pas en établissement
toutes les personnes âgées qui sont à
leur domicile
il faut leur permettre d'avoir une
solution pour se faire vacciner et dans
le département de l'ain
le conseil départemental de l'inde
je m'honore de faire partie a pris
l'initiative de contacter une à une
toutes les personnes âgées à domicile
bénéficiaires de l'apa l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie
nous les avons contactés si elle
acceptait de se faire vacciner nous leur
avons envoyé des véhicules nous sommes
allés les chercher chez elle nous les
avons amenés à des centres de
vaccination provisoire et nous les avons
emmenés à leur domicile
je crois que c'est ça qui est important
c'est le fond c'est l'action que nous
pouvons entreprendre pour que toutes ces
personnes à risque soient vaccinés ça
n'est pas seulement une question de
droit c'est une question de volonté et
monsieur le ministre il faut vous
appuyer davantage sur les collectivités
territoriales et particulièrement les
départements
donc j'aime et on voit le seul 882
puisque monsieur rue femme ne veut pas
aller au delà
l'avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour contre rejeté
le jury fin donc je vous en prie le
ministre en plus ça fait une réponse
particulièrement circonstanciée à
l'ensemble dû fuser c'est les mêmes
sujets on va pas décliner toutes les
maladies de la terre je veux dire à un
moment donné mais si vous avez la parole
pour lui 185
je comprends ce que vous dites monsieur
plaisant mais sachez que pour moi on est
là un point clé de la discussion
pourquoi 1 parce que on a le choix entre
deux logiques
soit on est sur une logique de ciblage
et se demandait comment on fait pour
mettre tous nos efforts mais tous nos
efforts pour aller chercher les cinq
millions personnes qui ont des
comorbidités plus les deux millions
personnes âgées qui sont à risque et qui
aujourd'hui sont pas vaccinés soit faute
de faire ça qu'est ce qu'on fait on
arrose tout azimut et là le choix fait
par le gouvernement
en passant par le passé ni terre qui est
en vérité aller vers la vaccination
obligatoire pour tout le monde
ses deux plus défi
j'ai mais il ya un certain nombre de
d'experts en effet ni biologique qui
s'exprime là dessus merci donc monsieur
rapporteur défavorable chez ministre dé
la parole non très rapidement monsieur
rifains c'est pas le gouvernement vous
pointer là ce sont les dizaines de
milliers de personnes deux soignantes
agents des collectivités des
départements ça a été dit des mairies
des ccas tous les soignants les médecins
les pharmaciens qui vous écoutent et qui
se disent on est en train de nous dire
qu'on fait pas notre boulot
ils sont mobilisés depuis des mois pour
le faire c'était un moment donné un
moment donné comme on voulait faire de
la politique à tous crins regarder à qui
vous adressez contacter monsieur rufin
les associations qui sont réunis en
visio toutes les semaines pour le pour
les accompagner dans les démarches
d'aller vers le lait versé 650 mille
patients qui ont été vaccinés grâce aux
démarches de aller vers 92 % des
établissements collectifs dans la seule
dans l'aide dans le domaine de la
solidarité qui ont été couverts par la
vaccination grâce aux allées versé 2108
opération ciblée devant des publics
précaires 1424 opérations ciblées vers
les territoires sous vacciner parce
qu'on fonctionne aussi en terme de
territoire se vacciner et on va là
croyez moi monsieur reford pas grand
monde ne va et vous non plus mais sir
deux orateurs inscrits monsieur jumelles
et monsieur emilienne monsieur jumelles
d'abord
non monsieur je je je trouve que alors
que les amendements sont constructifs
répondre avec une posture aussi
caricaturale ne rehausse pas lé débat je
je je le dis très tranquillement
écoutez le président si je peux avoir un
peu de silence pour m'exprimer
pour le coup les ministres a répondu
vraiment sur le fond devant bêtise mais
vous avez la parole
écoutez il ya une réalité objective
c'est que plus les difficultés sociales
sont présentent plus les obstacles
culturels économiques géographiques dont
l'accès aux soins en dehors de la crise
sont existants vous le savez et donc les
publics les plus fragiles pour l'instant
nous avons des difficultés pour les
sensibiliser sur l'enjeu vaccinale nous
ne disons pas que rien n'est fait moi je
préside une conférence de territoire de
santé ou depuis de nombreuses semaines
de nombreux mois on développe tout un
tas d'initiatives pour aller vacciner
les gens vaccinaux bus etc
mais malgré cela des pans entiers et
notamment les plus fragiles y compris
ceux qui n'ont pas de médecin référent
parce que vous vous rend compte
vous êtes au pays de oui oui elle est il
ya des gens qu'on pas toubib
il ya même des zones de déserts médicaux
il ya même des endroits où avoir un
médecin référent c'est impossible
il est faux monsieur le ministre alors
on vous a pas tout dit de dire que
partout dans les départements les cpm
ont été mobilisés pour appeler un par un
les personnes non vaccinées
renseignez-vous en seine maritime en
normandie les gens n'ont pas été appelés
un par un pour leur proposer un
rendez-vous dans la proximité
c'est ce qu'on vous propose à travers
les amendements constructif qui sont mis
au débat entendait que entendez que nous
sommes pour la vaccination
entendez que nous pensons que pour
sortir de la crise il faut atteindre un
taux de vaccination maximum et que nous
sommes tellement pressé de cela
nous avons bien vu que votre pass
sanitaire va discriminer ceux qui sont
déjà les plus fragilisés
géographiquement socialement
culturellement
financièrement c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposons des
amendements qui visent à merci vous
allez améliorer la réponse merci
monsieur le président monsieur enfin je
veux dire que je suis d'accord avec vous
comme l'a dit monsieur le ministre mais
là dans votre argumentation votre
argumentation m'attriste en fait parce
que je ne sais pas dans votre
département
parce que je n'irai pas à juger dans
votre département dans le nuage peux
vous assurer que tout est fait pour
aller chercher ces personnes absolument
tout est fait de la part des personnels
de santé bien évidemment de la cpam et
de tous ces gens là mais également de
jean d'élus locaux qui sont pas
forcément de notre bord et qui font tous
les efforts pour aller chercher ces gens
là donc dans cet hémicycle à part vous
monsieur rufin peut-être tous les autres
toutes les autres présentent ativités
des différents partis politiques font
l'effort d'aller chercher ces personnes
isolées pour qu'elles soient vaccinées
alors oui il reste un problème et vous
avez raison mais ça je ne sais pas si
par la loi on arrivera à le résoudre
parce que quand une personne en
comorbidités refuse vraiment de se faire
vacciner
moi si vous avez
petit truc magique pour l'a décidé eh
ben je veux bien vous l'emprunter est
allé chercher et aidez moi même à faire
vacciner cette personne mais c'est pas
par la loi vous y arriverons merci je me
revois le seul 885 avis défavorable de
la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour contre rejeté 886 mesure une fin
pour l'instant en tout cas j'ai pas
d'explication à pourquoi la france est
le dernier pays d'europe de l'ouest
quant à la vaccination des plus fragiles
et le 15e pays d'europe
sinon le rapport du comité scientifique
monsieur le ministre vous dites c'est
comme si j'accusais les soignants ne pas
faire leur travail ainsi suite non ce
que je demande moi c'est quand est-ce
qui a la volonté politique de mettre
tout le monde en branle
quand le président de la république
apparaît à la télévision c'est avec
l'autorité et la matraque
c'est pas en se demandant comment on va
mettre en branle partout dans le pays
tous les relais possibles pour père veut
pour se fixer à cet objectif là et qu'on
est donc dans un un arrosage généralisée
là ce qui est en cause
avec ses 5 millions de personnes moi
comme en mobilité non vaccinés et sur
lequel la discussion ne porte pas
pendant les heures et les heures de
débat le seul moment où sa porte là
dessus c'est au moment où je dépose une
série d'amendements sur ça et on
croirait presque que ça ne fait pas
partie du débat ça devrait être le coeur
du débat
ça devrait être le coeur de la question
est donc moi ce que je mets en cause là
c'est la capacité à mettre en branle les
acteurs divers et variés merci monsieur
à porter des faveurs à monsieur le
ministre est favorable
donc je mets deux voies qui est pour
contre goethe et monsieur phal 1130
défendu merci défavorable commission des
femmes au gouvernement
mais je vois qu'ils aient pour contre
rejeté monsieur ruffat 2124 la jugeant
que j'en conviens on change un peu le
sujet
nous sommes contre le pas salutaire nous
sommes contre le pass sanitaires pour
les mineures mais enfin si jamais il n'y
a pas de sanitaires on n'adapte pas la
science à la parole du président comment
ça se fait que jusqu'à maintenant
c'était 14 jours après le vaccin qu'on
était encore en situation de d'attraper
le coc vide et que maintenant ça passe à
16 joue sept jours le docteur jérôme
marty il dit c'est une décision qui est
plus économique et sociale que sanitaire
en vérité c'est plus une décision
politique c'est comme s'il y avait un
ordre qui venait d'être donné au vac au
virus
les études citées poursuit ce médecin
par le ministre la santé ne tiennent pas
compte du variant delta elle porte sur
et votre autre variant et il poursuit
pas sûr que sept jours après la deuxième
dose on est suffisamment propre projet
face aux variants delta il faut noter
par ailleurs que au niveau de l'union
européenne
les règles n'ont pas bougé on est
toujours inchangée la parole du
président réussi à changer ce que
produisait le vaccin et le virus au
niveau français sap a encore réussi à
changer ce que produisait le vaccin et
le virus au niveau européen puisque au
niveau européen ça reste à 14 jours mais
ces rapporteurs défavorable monsieur le
ministre défavorable se sont forgés oui
merci monsieur le président gt gt
pendant curieux par la proche que
monsieur rufin défendent approche un peu
différenciée est intéressé et en ce sens
je souhaiterais questionné le ministre
sur cette question parce que c'est ce
que j'essaie de proposer lors de ma
première intervention en sortant de la
prise de position militante
est ce que pour éviter cette question du
passé ni terre et donc la peur
d'atteintes aux libertés collectives
individuelles
est ce que on ne peut pas est-ce que
vous ne pouvez pas penser à temporiser
la vaccination des personnes non à
risque
information à nous donner sur la
disponibilité à venir par exemple du
vaccin protéines recombinantes français
encore franco britannique de d'autres
vaccins en cours de développement
peut-être de l'ouverture à certains
vaccins qu'ils sont peut-être pas
reconnu par l'agencé européenne du
médicament mais qui prouve une
efficacité dont deux grands piliers dans
lesquelles ils ont été développés et dès
lors continuer une approche de
vaccination ciblée des plus fragiles
avec des vaccins plus expérimentaux avec
peut-être un peu plus d'effets
secondaires certains impossible à
évaluer avec seulement une année de
recul et dans ce cas là le rapport
bénéfices risques est accessible pour
cette population à risque et vous
temporiser avec des vaccins plus
classique où on a un recul sur la
méthodologie pour des populations à
risque avec je l'entends l'intérêt
d'aller vers une couverture vaccinale la
plus large possible pour que la
politique vaccinale en soi soit efficace
si vous avez cette approche différenciée
on peut éviter le passé ni terre et si
c'est une question de quelques semaines
de quelques mois pensez vous monsieur le
ministre que cesson envisageable d'aller
vers cette alternative
je remercie la parole oui mais je veux
dire je sais l'ubu roi qui continuent
tout à l'heure ça circule en tgv mais ça
circule pas dans le erreur est là ubu
décide que ça sera sept jours pendant
lequel on continue à avoir de la
contagiosité est et à la place de de 14
jours je pense que ça mérite une
explication scientifique sinon comment
les français peuvent prendre au sérieux
avoir confiance dans votre science quand
d'un seul coup on passe le délai de 14
jours à 7 jours alors qu'on leur a
raconté pendant des mois que c'était 14
jours et avec 0 explications alors donc
je mets au voile 1124 défavorable
commission gouvernement qui est pour
contre jeter le 1064 et monsieur rufin
oui
le vaccin ça fait des mois qu'on demande
qu'ils soient produits en france ça fait
deux mois qu'on demande qui est une
levée les brevets pour les pays du sud
donc il est évident que pour nous le
vaccin appartient l'arsenal face au co
vite 19 mai il faut pas que ça aille
avec un abandon des autres remèdes
or qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qui se
passe là c'est qu'on nous dit qu'on va
abandonner les tests alors que les tests
peuvent être à la fois un outil contre
le virus
on a cette note qui nous est donnée par
l'université de bonn pour 42% la
population allemande en 12h21
les tests ont joué un rôle plus crucial
dans la forte baisse des taux
d'infection que les vaccins le test
reste un outil pas se couvrir et surtout
le test peut être une vraie alternative
pour les réticents à la vaccination
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on
devrait avoir des moyens qui choie
soucier à cette loi des moyens pour
déployer les tests partout pour les
déployer avec les pharmacies pour les
déployer devant les bars non non il y en
a pas partout
quand vous regardez quand vous regardez
la carte des zones de test en allemagne
vous avez des petits points qui
apparaissent devant tous les bars tous
les cinémas et ainsi de suite
pourquoi pour prépare proposer une vraie
yasmine sur une feinte défavorable
commission défavorable gouvernement
madame adadja parole puis le président
mais la chance merci monsieur le
président je voulais
dix romans pour ne pas créer la
confusion dans ce qui peut être dit ici
dans cet hémicycle
moi je tiens à saluer l'effort et
l'engagement de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé l'ensemble des
acteurs du territoire
l'ensemble des centres sociaux qui
effectivement sont unanimement mobilisés
dans cet effort national qui est celui
en faveur de la vaccination
shia salué la mise en oeuvre sur
certains territoires de la démarche
d'aller vers qui me semble être
aujourd'hui l'un des leviers majeurs
pour nous permettre d'accélérer cet
effort de vaccination
j'ai entendu j'ai écouté très
attentivement votre propos monsieur le
ministre sur la question de la plate
forme d'appels téléphoniques sortant
dont je salue
effectivement le travail qui de ce que
j'en comprends aujourd'hui réservé aux
plus de 75 ans sauf si vous me dites le
contraire mais j'ai pas trouvé d'autres
données sur le site de l'assurance
maladie elles sont elles sont jusqu'à
les données datent du 31 mars dernier et
c'est là dessus qu'il ya un petit un
petit bémol à mon sens puisque dans
l'avis de la haute autorité de santé du
1er juillet dernier sur la question de
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
et sur les préconisations qui sont
émises cette démarche d'aller vers elle
doit être étendue selon cette même
préconisations à certains publics
fragiles et on le voit bien aujourd'hui
sur les données de vaccination dont on
dispose et je vais parler principalement
de la métropole de grandes paris où on a
des disparités extrêmement importante en
fonction des communes en fonction des
quartiers
personnellement je suis dans le 20e
arrondissement de paris entre les
quartiers des maréchaux et le centre de
l'arrondissement clairement les données
de vaccination les pénétrations d'avec
la vaccination n'est pas du tout la même
et donc là dessus comment est-ce que ce
ciblage peut être intensifiées comment
est-ce qu'on peut accélérer accompagner
aider et notamment les collectivités
territoriales je pense aussi ils sont
prêtes ses sens de l'amendement qu'on
avait porté tout à l'heure et je le
regrette qu'il n'a pas été retenu elles
peuvent accompagner cette démarche là je
pense qu'on est toutes et tous ceux
prêts de façon à augmenter la couverture
vaccinale
merci mais la parole argument à la
pertinence de ce qui vient d'être dit à
propos de cet amendement le premier j'y
reviens permettez moi de vous dire que
ce ne sera pas le moindre dans les mois
que nous connaîtrons c'est le pull
man d'énormes papier attestation à
contrôler par les uns par les autres qui
servent ou ne servent pas ce matin
descendant de l'avion
je m'avance fièrement dans la file
compte amis vacciner et quand j'arrive
au bout de ma fille vacciner je sors mon
papier de vaccin car je suis vacciné on
me dit inutile
nous nous contentons du test alors
suivant les endroits on demandera une
chose on n'en demandera une autre et
vous verrez que nonobstant que quelle
que soit la bonne volonté des décideurs
chacun de ceux qui auront le petit
pouvoir de contrôle et ne manqueront pas
de le faire et d'y ajouter leur touche
personnelle
deuxième élément monsieur le ministre
qui lui mac est un peu plus et je vais
attendre la réponse que vous nous ferez
avec de l'intérêt parce que françois
ruffin a soulevé une question importante
être vaccinés n'exempte pas d'être
contaminés être vaccinés n'exempte pas
d'être contaminés si vous êtes vacciné
et que vous avez la certitude qu à
partir de là vous ne pouvez pas
contaminer les autres
vous devenez dangereux parce que vous
pouvez contaminer les autres est d'ores
et déjà nous avons des résultats de
jeunes gens qui nous explique qu'étant
vacciner ils ont participé à une soirée
ils ont été contaminées mais ils sont
prévenus parce qu'ils sont qu'à
contacter pour ma part j'applique le
principe de morale de la responsabilité
individuelle absolue dès lors puisque je
suis vacciné je pense que je me ferais
testé dans un certain nombre de
circonstances
j'en ai le moyen financier ce n'est pas
le cas de tout le monde
je vous mets en garde dirk être vaccinés
à lui la nécessité des tests qu'ils
seront payants fait que par ce moyen
nous pouvons développer la contamination
de marge mais vainement de rejet d'un
jeu qui ne peuvent pas être vaccinés
je me revois 2064 défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour contre rejeté
le 1043 convenait mieux référencer le
même sujet et quand même hein
c'est bien tant que c'est pas un sujet
négligeable pourquoi parce que là il ya
le vaccin qui nous est présenté comme un
remède miracle hier et vous verrez que
ça figurent au compte rendu des débats
le ministre vert en 8es si tout le monde
est vacciné il n'y a plus de virus
c'est scientifiquement faux s'était dit
hier c'est scientifiquement faux et je
dirais que là l'idée cette idée qu avec
pas sanitaire et vaccination obligatoire
on élimine le virus c'est à la fois
catastrophique pour les libertés
et c'est dangereux pour la santé parce
qu'avec ce raisonnement on se prive d'un
tas d'autres outils
d'autres outils de lutte contre le
comique comme les tests on a cet article
on nous dit en allemagne il est possible
d'avoir deux tests pcr gratuit par
semaine et il y à des stands par tout
cela de sorte à ne pas obliger les gens
à se vacciner c'est à dire de manière à
proposer une véritable alternative
si aujourd'hui en france n'existe pas
parce que c'est compliqué parce qu'en
plus
bientôt vous éliminerez ce moyen en le
rendant payants et je pense que là ça
témoigne de coin ça témoigne encore
d'une absence de politique de soins
général en misant tout sur le vaccin
vous allez précipité les français dans
de nouvelles désillusions dans des
déceptions tandis que évidemment face à
ce virus c'est qu'il nous faut c'est une
palette d'outils simek le bac ça qui est
un outil parmi ces outils défavorable
commission peut-être sans crier
monsieur rifains je je je pense que vous
évoluez dans le même pays que nous ici
vous n'avez pas pu passer à côté depuis
un an et demi d'une donnée à 7 ans gil
blas et vérifiable c'est que la france
met à disposition de tous ceux qui en
ont besoin ou tous ceux qui le
souhaitent des millions de tests pcr des
tests antigénique gratuit nous sommes le
seul pays à le faire
n'allez quand même pas nous exposer le
modèle allemand pour nous dire que
financerait des tests que nous ne
finançons rions pas si vous êtes en
train de vous fonder sur la base de la
la possibilité de projeter la fin du
remboursement de tests récréatif lorsque
toute la peau
il a sion se serait vu proposer le
vaccin et au delà de la vague épidémique
j'ai envie de vous dire que nous n'y
sommes pas encore
2 n'allez quand même pas essayé de faire
prendre les nounous prend du temps des
français pour des jambons leur
expliquant que les tests seraient
payants en france alors qu'il serait
gratuit en allemagne celle inverse
c'était exactement l inverse c'est
exactement la mer donc je me dis je me
dis j'ai entendu que le président
mélenchon étaient à l'aéroport
aujourd'hui je me dis que c'était pas un
vol intérieur vous dire venir de
l'étranger parce que j'ai compris que
vous ne preniez pas l'avion pour les
vols intérieurs mais vous vivez quand
même dans le même pays que nous vous
êtes au courant
bah oui vous êtes quand même au courant
que les tests sont gratuits bien moins
mais je suis heureux je suis savez savez
parfois parfois l'arrogance parfois
parfois l'arrogance ça prend la forme du
cynisme monsieur corbières on n'est pas
obligé d'être agressif j'essaie de ne
pas être agressif parce que votre vote
l'agressivité vous nous renvoyez à
longueur de journée de nuisance
hémicycle écoute vous avez moi je suis
contre toute forme de violence
je suis contre la violence sociale je
suis content la violence intérêts
individuels
donc est ce que vous auriez vous savez
on sait que vous je vous réponds je vous
répond avec le sourire et vous prenez ça
pour de l'arrogance je pourrais vous
insultez vous crier dessus comme vous le
faites mais ce n'est pas dans mon état
d'esprit et ce n'est pas comme ça que
j'ai été élevé et monsieur corbières
j'ai été éduqué pour ne pas crier sur
les gens je crois que le respect est une
valeur solide dans la société surtout
par les temps qui courent je continue
monsieur rifains il ya eu une maladie
bientôt deux maladies infectieuses qui
ont été éradiqués de la planète les
connaissez vous vous qui dites que le
vaccin n'éradique pas les maladies que
c'est faux scientifiquement la seule
maladie qui a été éradiquée de la
planète
monsieur rufin elle s'appelle la variole
et vous savez comment la ra dickey par
la vaccination avec l'immunité
collective savez la deuxième la deuxième
maladie infectieuse qui est en passe
d'être éradiquée qui existent encore par
petits foyers infectieux çà et là mais
qui est très loin de d'envahir le monde
et la planète comme elle l'a fait
pendant des années qui était la première
cause de mortalité infantile
il ya encore quelques décennies en
france c'est la poliomyélite et comment
est ce qu'on a fait la vaccination avec
l'immunité collective
vous savez comment on a fait reculer de
95% les maladies infectieuses qui
rendrait les enfants sourds ou donner
des encéphalites comme la rougeole la
rubéole etc
je vous donne dans le mille et mille la
vaccination avec l'immunité collective
donc essayons d'être factuel s'il vous
plaît ne faisons pas injure à la science
quant à la question que me posais
monsieur mélenchon présent mélenchon qui
était factuel je vous fais une réponse
factuel ce que nous savons à date c'est
que la vaccination réduit au moins la
contagiosité par 12 par 12
donc ça veut dire que le risque n'est
pas à dire je n'en sais rien mais vous
avez raison monsieur coquerel je vais
dire je vais lire le manifeste de la
france est soumise et je viens
d'apprendre plus que dans toutes les
revues littérature mondiale publié
semaine après semaine avec des dizaines
de milliers de scientifiques qui eux
connaissent un petit peu mieux le métier
que vous et moi réuni monsieur qu'aux
faibles
bref vous avez ce facteur de réduction
de contagiosité
le vaccin est efficace et je noterai je
noterai cette petite
permettez-moi de le dire cette toute
petite ambiguïté qui a toujours chez
vous vous êtes en train de nous dire que
l'impératif l'impérieuse nécessité c'est
d'inciter tout le monde à se faire
vacciner notamment les plus fragiles et
les malades mais j'aimerais bien vous
entendre le dire faites vous vacciner
j'aimerais bien vous voir twitté faites
vous vacciner
j'aimerais bien que vous n'ayez pas un
discours
figue mi raisin sur le vaccin tantôt
bondir qu'on devine pas content vaccine
pas assez et tantôt pour rappeler que le
vaccin c'est peut-être pas si bien que
ça tantôt pour dire qu on vaccine pas
assez tôt pour nous dire est ce qu'on
est vraiment sûr que la vaccination
c'est la solution à tout voyez mesdames
et messieurs les députés encore une fois
le courage en politique c'est de prendre
une position de l'assumer avec droiture
et à déclarté la parole et à madame
legault d'eau qui connaît le métier de
la pharmacie merci madame firmin le bodo
je suis marié moi je voudrais répondre à
monsieur rufin qui nous racontent
souvent les histoires de brigitte
monique roberte moi j'invite monsieur
rufin si nous terminons l'examen du
texte cette nuit à venir avec moi à la
pharmacie demain matin à 9h et à la
rentrée parlementaire de raconter
l'histoire d'agnès à la pharmacie qui
teste qui vaccinent juste pour dire que
les tous les professionnels de santé de
ville sont fortement mobilisés pour
tester et testé massivement monsieur fin
vacciner et vacciner massivement
donc merci de ceci étant j'ai une
question pour monsieur le ministre dans
le cadre du aller vers est ce que vous
pourriez monsieur ministre donnait
l'autorisation pendant cette période de
crise sanitaire aux professionnels de
santé les pharmaciens les médecins
d'aller vacciner à domicile et notamment
toutes les personnes qui ne peuvent pas
sortir de chez elle en accord avec les
infirmières je voudrais dire mon accord
avec le ministre sur un point en effet
la variole a été éradiquée par une
campagne de matchs mondiale initiée par
l'urss après une un plan présenté devant
l'ot est neuf et je reviens du burkina
oui c'est pas vous qui l'avez fait
c'est pas vous et pour y parvenir on a
distribué en match le vaccin contre la
variole
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est vous qui vous
opposer à la liste libre sur les vaccins
vous qui lui demander d'avoir le courage
de nos opinions que nous payons souvent
si cher qu'à n'en manquons pas et nous
ne manquerons pas c'est votre
gouvernement qui accepte qu à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
on décide que le vaccin reste une
marchandise alors qu'en france jusqu'en
1959 il était interdit de déposer un
brevet sur un vaccin alors je vous le
dit avec le sourire monsieur véran il
vous faudra avoir le courage d'aller au
bout de vos opinions
vous aussi car il est apparent que vous
ne le faites pas j'ajoute que vous nous
demander d'intervenir nous le faisons
d'une manière qui n'est pas la vôtre
nous croyons à la conviction nous
croyons à la vertu de l'exemple et nous
sommes respectueux de la liberté car si
l'organisation mondiale de la santé dit
qu'il vaut mieux convaincre que
contraindre c'est parce qu'elle sait que
quand on invente des passes sanitaire
des contrôles à tout bout de champ de la
paperasse enfin on crée une autre
société que celle dans laquelle nous
voulons vivre
c'est la raison pour laquelle la liberté
la production c'est de montrer comment
on agit mais vous avez pris une décision
c'est de rendre payant le test en
rendant payant le texte même le test
même en divisant par 1600 cas cités de
contamination j'achève là dessus elles
existent monsieur vers ans et vous
prenez la responsabilité personnelle
après avoir du temps de chaudes et son
contraire dans cet hémicycle vous prenez
la responsabilité personnelle de nous
empêcher quand on n'a pas les moyens
d'assumer des responsabilités d'êtres
humains trois des favoris commission
ou qui est contre rejeté le 1140 là
c'est exactement le même un jury fins et
les pharmacies les les stands
sauf que cet amendement a franchi le cap
de la recevabilité et je ne conteste pas
très bien je vous remercie monsieur
payant j'ai entendu le ministre qui a
parlé de la fin des tests récréatif ya
maintenant des caisses qui va rigoler en
se faisant des tests
la vérité c'est que vous avez décidé de
mettre fin à la gratuité de ces tests à
l'automne opérant un tri des
porte-monnaie parce que le virus déjà il
prend le tgv mais prend pas le métro
mais là le le virus en fonction de la
taille des porte monnaie il va
contaminer ou ne plus contaminé c'est à
dire que parce que vous misez tout sur
le vaccin
vous faites vous produisez de l'abandon
d'autres outils là où ses autres outils
je vous dis pas qu'ils sont inexistants
mais qu'il faudrait les développer
qu'ils soient en pharmacie c'est une
bonne chose
il en faudrait dans tous les cantons je
vais même proposé qu'il y en ait dans un
certain nombre de zones de test pour
mille pour 1000 habitants
mais vous regardez en allemagne qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils ont des tests devant
tous les bars les cinémas et ainsi de
suite
quand on veut rentrer on se teste à
l'entrée non pas payant avec un certain
nombre de corps au nab ax aussi qui
viennent proposer des tests aux
habitants et l'université de bonn dit
que par ce biais là ça a été plus
efficace pour diminuer le virus que la
vaccination elle même donc ça veut dire
que c'est un outil qui n'est pas éliminé
est toute la question c'est pas grave je
prends un gouvernement et pour contre je
t'ai 1060 détient une moyenne de 40 tout
à l'heure maintenant les pcr 24 c'est à
dire qu'on est plus à 13 heures demain
on est on est vers les 17 heures 18
heures demain mais sur iphone vous
parliez monsieur le ministre de la
fermeté des convictions c'est pas nous
qui il ya quelques mois jurion la main
sur le coeur que l'aveu leur excitation
ne serait jamais obligatoire et que le
pack sanitaire ne se ferait pas pour les
actes du quotidien
je cite l'exemple de l'allemagne où les
tests sont multipliés partout mais que
vous dis madame merkel
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse gagner la
confiance en changeant ce que nous avons
dit c'est à dire pas de vaccination
obligatoire nous n'avons pas l'intention
de suivre la voie que la france vient de
proposer et donc là c'est monsieur le
ministre comment vous faites maintenant
vous rendez la vie impossible aux gens
qui sont réticents à se faire vacciner
comment vous faites pour leur ouvrir une
autre voie une voie alternative qui fait
qu' ils peuvent continuer à vivre dans
notre pays
ils peuvent accéder à des tests
régulièrement et ils risquent pas de
continuer leur entourage leur collègue
leur lieu de travail
en programmant la fin des tests gratuits
pour l'automne au fond vous mener une
politique anti sanitaires si des favoris
a promis qu'un gouvernement qui est pour
contre jeter les 1135 défendu des foires
commission gouvernement je vais devoir
qui est pour contre jeter les 277
monsieur blanche
monsieur blanchet n'est pas défendu pas
défendu défendu pardonnez-moi
défavorable que messieurs gouvernement
je vais devoir qui est pour contre je
t'ai monsieur nay est défendu de 480
vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le président très
rapidement nous savons tous que la
pratique d'activités culturelles de
loisirs sportives chez les plus jeunes
je pense à aux jeunes de 12 à 17 ans et
souvent corrélée à la au niveau social
au niveau culturel des parents et
lorsque des enfants de familles modestes
pratiquer ces activités là nous devons
le salut et l'encouragé bien sûr lorsque
des mers et je pense à mon territoire à
la réunion l'heure
que des maires envoie les enfants faire
du soutien scolaire dans des centres de
soutien scolaire nous devons bien sûr
saluer et encourager la démarche mais il
faut le dire que le pass sanitaire sera
un frein sera une difficulté
supplémentaire puisque forcément sur un
territoire où le taux de vaccination
aujourd'hui est d'un peu d'à peu près
30% où il est quasiment inexistant chez
les plus jeunes
il va y avoir un recul important c'est
pour cela que je demande pour le
territoire de la réunion
la non application du pass sanitaires
pour les 12 17 ans merci monsieur le
rapporteur est pour oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président simplement à
l'occasion de cet amendement sur les 12
17 ans monsieur le ministre une question
très précise vous savez que nous avons
beaucoup trop de réticences vis-à-vis du
pass sanitaire et si on rentre justement
dans l'application il ya un point qui
est assez troublant d'un côté on indique
qu' à partir de 12 ans il y à des
situations dans lesquelles il faut le
pass sanitaires mais de la même manière
on indique que pour être vacciné il faut
absolument être âgés de 12 ans et donc
comment allez vous concrètement faire
pour me permettre à des jeunes qui à la
fois devront avoir le pass annie terre
dès l'âge de 12 ans mais qui par
ailleurs ne pourront pas se faire
vacciner avant l'âge de 12 ans il ya là
une situation un peu problématique et
j'aimerais sur ce point précis à
entendre le la réponse du gouvernement
donc j'aime et de voie d'amendement 480
qui est pour compte
rejetée mathieu cosse le 807 la parole
merci à monsieur prison donc cet
amendement vise à faciliter l'accès aux
lieux concernés par l'obligation de
présentation du pass sanitaires aux
personnes exemptées de l'obligation
vaccinale
derrière ces exemptions aux obligations
d'immunisation se cachent de nombreuses
situations histoire personnelle
impliquant parfois des pathologies
graves
il s'agit donc de permettre à ces
personnes de pouvoir continuer à
bénéficier d'un accès aux lieux recevant
du public en toute facilité et en toute
responsabilité afin qu'il puisse
retrouver proches amis et famille au
moment où ils en ont réellement
besoin donc en fait cet amendement
propose de prendre en considération des
personnes qui aujourd'hui sont dans un
angle mort de la loi merci défavorable
commission gouvernement je mets aux voix
qui époux l'arrivée mam gatel oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez répondu avant-hier à
ma collègue laure ding rocard sur les
contre-indications extrêmement rare de
est identifiée du vaccin donc de
syndrome pims et puis l'allergie au p au
p e g alors s'il ya très peu de contre
indications structurelles ce qui doit
insister inciter tous nos concitoyens se
faire vacciner
il peut en revanche y avoir des contre
indications conjoncturel dans le cas
notamment de la mise en place de
protocoles de soins pour des pathologies
lourdes et invalidante
alors parce par cet amendement
laissons permettons aux médecins dans un
cadre strict de délivrer une
certification de contre-indication
vaccinale provisoire le médecin engage
sa responsabilité
le dispositif est placé sous l'égide du
conseil de l'ordre pour prévenir toute
dérive autorisons nous cette souplesse
pour des patients très spécifique avec
la possibilité de mettre en place ce
certificat de contrôle vaccination
provisoire je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je vous le dis tout de suite
c'est une pente savonneuse et je suis
une porte en faux contre la notion même
de contre-indication conjoncturelle j'ai
sollicité nous avons sollicité toutes
les autorités sanitaires tout tous les
acteurs amené à se prononcer ce que vous
dites et pardon madame la députée n'est
actuellement pas conforme à la vérité il
n'ya pas de protocole de soins qui
empêche d'avoir la vaccination tiko vide
il n'y a pas de diminuer dépression qui
empêche d'avoir la vaccination qui
qu'ovide n'y a pas de traitement par
immunoglobulines qui empêche d'avoir la
vaccination tiko vide c'est faux la
liste elle est connue ces chocs
anaphylactiques péricardite myocardite
et puis hépatite c vert ayant entraîné
une hospitalisation à la suite d'une
première injection de vaccin de comptes
locaux vides c'est l'allergie au peg
vous l'avez dit c'est le pym's et le
kawasaki chez l'enfant
donc ces quelques centaines de personnes
et je leur dis pas ce que je veux on a
beaucoup débattu en commission
pardon mais quand ya des sujets qui ont
été débattus en commission ont
longuement je veux pas reprendre chaque
fois chaque délibération même si
sont déposés par des députés de la
majorité pardonnez moi pour ça sinon on
va pas s'en sortir semble que c'est un
peu aussi la règle du jeu à nouveau pour
toutes les personnes qui ont cette
contre-indication ce sera pas un
certificat vaccinale de contre
indications qui sera recevable
c'est une scène ça nécessite une
expertise et toutes les personnes qui
sont concernées au rang de solutions
individuelles pour que personne ne soit
pénalisé évidemment et je vous redis 20
% des français seraient allergiques
graves à des antibiotiques si on
écoutait des certificats de
contre-indication à aux antibiotiques
alors qu'en réalité c'est moins de 3 %
de population donc ne rentrons pas la
donne en s'il vous plaît sinon on va
vraiment pas s'en sortir
chaque situation individuelle aura une
solution individuelle avec humanité je
mets donc pouvoir lui cinq sets qui est
pour contre rejeté discussion comme une
même salle à 785 madame dupont 785 oui
pardon je suis président je n'ai pas vu
que ma collègue avait été contrainte de
quitter l'hémicycle
donc nathalie ça dans cet amendement
propose que le parcours vaccinale
initiés c'est à dire à partir du moment
où on a commencé et qu'on a eu le
premier vaccin est bien que cela
permette d'apporter et souplesse
nécessaire j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
question des professionnels du bâtiment
j'ai demandé des explications après
l'explication du rapporte que je n'ai
pas comprises
eh bien ces professionnels demain ne
pourront plus manger en restauration dès
la promulgation de la loi
je crois vraiment qu'on a besoin de
souplesse dans ce texte si on veut être
efficace si on veut que les français
l'appliquent pleinement dont je crois
que cet amendement proposait aussi par
un collègue broudic va dans le bon sens
merci
non défendu avec la commission oui
monsieur le président on sait que c'est
fou deux vaccinations peut avoir la
protection maximale donc avis
défavorable également jeu mais je vois
le 785g pour contre rejeté 835 et pour
contre rejeté
monsieur nay et 209 défendu défavorable
commission gouvernement genevois qui est
pour contre je t il s'en dit ce n'est
pas défendu le 680 non plus un congé
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre l'objet de cet amendement est
d'identifier tous les lieux
établissements événements pour lesquels
le pass sanitaire est exigé pour
renforcer l'obligation de présenter le
pass sanitaires et pour faciliter sa
mise en oeuvre
un affichage spécifique est réalisé sur
ces mêmes lieux
les modalités de cet affichage sont
définies par décret en conseil d'état
et je pense notamment un pictogramme
dédiés comme il existe déjà des
affichages pour l'obligation du port du
masque ou le respect des gestes
barrières je vous remercie
merci défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement genevois qui est pour
contre rejeté
nous venons en maintenant aux 157 qui
n'est pas défendu au 625 monsieur que
crel vous avez la parole se précipiter
mais indique dean un capteur merci ce
projet de loi a pour conséquence de père
et in fine et une distinction entre les
travailleurs détenteur de l'un des trois
documents demandés et les autres aient
reconnu une des dix inquiétudes
exprimées par clairet rond défenseur des
droits alors par cet amendement qui vise
à jaillir se poser mais un global opa
salutaire mais plus exactement c'est
soit la ligne a14 qui concerne justement
les salariés des établissements
concernés par la demande d'un pass
sanitaire en exigeant à ses salariés
d'avoir un pass sanitaires pour aller
travailler en réalité
vous ouvrez d'abord une discrimination
entre des salariés et d'autres c'est le
premier problème mais plus globalement
je crois que vous ouvrez une voie qui va
être celle d'une généralisation vous
dites il y as je vous ai entendu dire
est assurée mordicus que ça ne
concernera pas les lycées les
établissements et autres mais moi j'ai
entendu emmanuel macron lors de son
allocution
quand il a parlé du pass sanitaires il a
dit pour l'instant c'est les cafés les
restaurants etc et non en substance
expliqué qu'il se réservait parce que
c'est lui qui décide
le droit de l'étendre moi je crois qu au
bout d'un moment vous allez l'étendre en
réalité au monde professionnel et nous
ne sommes pas d'accord et je voudrais
dire que aujourd'hui déjà certains
employeurs vous devance certains
employeurs notamment par rapport à des
personnes en situation précaire ou
indépendantes aux auto-entrepreneurs
exige le pass sanitaires vous êtes en
train de faire une discrimination
vis-à-vis des salariés et j'allais dire
d'importer dans le monde du travail
cette mesure liberticide que vous
proposez par ailleurs merci madame bâtir
pour le le président en fait cet
amendement demandant la suppression de
l'alinéa 14 qui revient à rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour toutes les
personnes qui interviennent dans des
lieux établissements services ou
événements cités à l'article 1er du
présent projet de loi
cette mesure est disproportionnée et
vient en contradiction avec l'esprit de
cette loi qui tend à laisser aux
français le choix de la vaccination
je vous remercie merci monsieur rufin
2083 identique
mais on reçoit déjà un certain nombre de
courriers à la fois de la direction la
fnac qui annonce à ses salariés qu'il
faut qu'ils se fassent vacciner
sinon bah ça sera là risque d'un
licenciement
on a vu la même chose chez burger king
et là on à moi j'ai le le docteur moreau
chirurgien des hôpitaux qui m'alerte qui
me dit voilà ce que ça va donner
pour le département du rhône il faut
envisager le vacciner entre 10 et 15
mille personnes appartenant à la seule
catégorie des personnels de restauration
aux débits de boissons à répartir entre
les centres de vaccination les quelques
médecins pour la pluie on et sa
périphérie sur 60 centres de vaccination
5 seulement des places disponibles avant
le 1er août
tous les autres noms des disponibilités
qu'au delà souvent en milieu de mois
voire en septembre l'objectif est donc
de toute manière inatteignable en l'état
actuel des possibilités de vaccination
sans parler du nombre de doses
disponibles des autres catégories de
citoyens obligés de se faire vacciner
sous peine de sanctions là il est
évident que avec cette règle qu'il
s'agit de faire sauter vous envoyer des
milliers de personnes possiblement à
pôle emploi
c'est la conséquence et c'est la grande
inquiétude qui règne chez un certain
nombre de salariés ceux qui sont
réticents à faire se faire vacciner et
qui n'ont pas de réelles possibilités
alternatives qui ont la pression de leur
employeur et même celles qui voudraient
se mettre dans les règles et qui de
toute façon là n'auront ces nouvelles
règles que nous contestons et qui est de
toute façon là n'auront pas le temps
d'avoir un rendez-vous avant que ces
mesures n'entrent dans les faits merci
vous avez par alger à porter et lyon je
pense qu'il serait totalement incohérent
de pas doutes sur le plan sanitaire ne
pas demander aux salariés sûr qu'on va
demander au client
donc avis défavorable et si je suivais
votre raisonnement si je suivais votre
raisonnement alors je ne comprendrais
pas moi même pourquoi les policiers et
gendarmes par exemple ne seraient pas
soumis à cette règle là et qui demain
pourront aller au commissariat
travailler tranquillement sans avoir un
pass sanitaire valide
alors bien sûr vous me direz oui le
virus respecte l'uniforme comme dit mon
collègue rufin mais c'est pas et c'est
pas une question de mettre en cause les
policiers et gendarmes ils font leur
travail c'est laisser les décisions
gouvernementales qui sont en cause de
soumettre ou pas telle ou telle
profession ou telle règle est de mettre
en vigueur et donc je m'interroge encore
une fois ce qui vaut pour les policiers
les gendarmes se dire votre argumentaire
les argumentaires qu'on a sur les
plateaux télé des membres du
gouvernement c'est de dire oui mais ce
sont des citoyens comme les autres et
donc ils devront forcément avoir un pass
unitaire à jour puisqu'ils vont eux
mêmes au centre commercial ils vont eux
mêmes au restaurant etc
mais alors cet argument vaut aussi pour
les salariés vous mettez déjà
suffisamment de contraintes comme ça
pour ne pas ajouter les licenciements
enfin est-ce que vous pouvez entendre ça
est-ce que vous pouvez l'entendre
ou alors vous n'avez que le bâton à
l'esprit est vraiment encore une fois
convaincre c'est toujours mieux que
contraindre
[Musique]
merci donc je mets ou voir cette série
d'amendements identiques des fabris
gouvernement qui est pour contre je t'ai
monsieur gosselin 386
défendu le
1035 julie philibeaux oui merci monsieur
le président dans le même esprit que
celui de mon collègue philippe gaussent
l'âme avec une date différente
on l'a vu les discussions nous amène
quand même avoir que pour ceux qui sont
engagés dans un passeport dans un pass
dans un parcours vaccinale après les
déclarations du président il est
impossible de remplir les conditions du
pass sanitaire avant cinq six semaines
ça nous renvoie maintenant vers la fin
septembre donc le but de cet amendement
c'est de différer l'entrée en vigueur du
pass sanitaire de laisser à nos
concitoyens le temps de se mettre en
règle avec ses obligations de manière
transparente de manière loyale
pendant ce temps comme le point les
collectivités et c'est aussi à vous de
les aider davantage quand il ya les
files d'attentes qu'on constate dans nos
centres de vaccination et bien mettre le
paquet sur la vaccination et refaisons
et bien le bilan à la rentrée pour voir
s'il est encore des choses qui bloque
est donc une date au 30 septembre pour
l'entrée en vigueur
merci défavorable défavorable ministre
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
une nouvelle fois notre collègue di
filippo viennent défendre un amendement
l'amendement était également défendu un
amendement de philippe gosselin et d'un
certain nombre d'entre nous c'est une
même insupportable de voir qu'en
permanence la majorité le gouvernement
c'est non c'est non c'est non encore une
fois un moment donné sur un sujet comme
celui là vous avez une responsabilité
celle de créer de la concorde un jeu
comprend un peu mieux les propos de
monsieur macron il ya un an et demi
nous sommes en guerre je voudrais par
rapport à cela quand même dire regardez
ce qu'a dit le président allemand au
même moment
non nous ne sommes pas en guerre tout
ceci est un test d'humanité est ce que
je constate c'est que la brutalité avec
laquelle vous voulez traiter le peuple
français est en contradiction avec les
questions de santé parce que quand on
parle de santé il faut se préoccuper de
la concorde
et là encore une fois ne pas aller avec
des méthodes brutales
vous êtes en train de brutaliser nos
concitoyens alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé qu'il faut faire et un certain
nombre de propositions ont pour objectif
de faire en sorte que les choses se
passent bien vous êtes en train de tout
faire pour que cela se passe mal c'est
tout de même très inquiétant
j'espère une aile oui moi je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui a été dit et puis ce
qui était proposé auparavant parce que
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit à
quelques instants que il y avait tout un
dispositif qui était mis en place avec
les passerelles santé les associations
et cetera la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie qui faisait des appels pour
téléphoner que cela monsieur rufin lui
il proposait en plus de ce dispositif
donc des comités par bassin de vie de
façon à ce que l'on puisse aider à ce
niveau là vous avez dit c'est pas
possible pas fait rentrer ça dans la loi
bon je pense que c'était une bonne
proposition
maintenant on est dans l'obligation et
quand on est dans l'obligation c'est un
aveu de faiblesse
c'est parce que vous n'avez pas été à la
hauteur et donc vous obligez les gens et
voulait menacés de licenciement c'est
quand même quelque chose de très très
grave parce que pendant toute cette
période
tout le monde a mal vécu cette période y
compris des salariés qui est en temps
partiel y compris des salariés qui
recherchait des emplois et qui n'ont pas
trouvé d'emploi et là on dit par la
menace
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné vous serez
complètement lisse entier c'est
inadmissible de la part d'un
gouvernement
je pense que la meilleure méthode c'est
d'essayer de trouver des solutions comme
on les propose ici comme tous les
députés elle propose mais à chaque fois
vous n'écoutez pas vous écoute et que
vous vous jamais vous remettez en cause
jamais ce gouvernement se remet en cause
sa fait la 9e texte qu'on discute
concernant les mesures sanitaires et
c'est toujours la même chose j'ai
toujours les mêmes langages de même
élément de langage et à chaque fois vous
êtes droits dans nos bottes et vous ne
bougez pas et on va te retrouver avec un
deuxième texte dans quelques temps et
vous dirai la même chose
c'est inadmissible c'est inacceptable je
mets donc on voit ces amendements
d'abord le 386 des faveurs du
gouvernement qu'est pour con
rejetez 1035 mais ma vie mes votes 973
jumeaux lac dit merci monsieur le
président donc cet amendement est un
amendement de repli qu'est vise à
étendre jusqu au 30 août en fait à
partir du 30 au de passer ce fameux pass
sanitaires alors pourquoi parce que
d'abord évidemment comme on a expliqué
ici bien des fois si vous commencez
aujourd'hui à vous vacciner de toute
façon il faudra attendre un certain
temps vous puissiez lettre ait donc là
honnêtement même ceux qui veulent être
vaccinés ne peuvent pas l'être
en plus nous sommes en pleine saison
touristique est forcément le fait de
voir un passé d'être obligé de le
présenter fait qu'un certain nombre de
personnes ne vont plus alors non
seulement dans les races temps mais
aussi dans les parcs d'attraction je
peux vous dire que j'ai reçu un message
de quelqu'un qui tient un parc
d'attractions un petit parc
d'attractions on va pas avoir le virus
qui va se déplacer à une grande vitesse
premier jour de passes sanitaire 40 % de
fréquentation en moins
donc là on voit bien qu'un certain
nombre de nos équipements vont être mis
en difficulté équipements touristiques
avec ce type de passe et on parlait tout
à l'heure
effectivement d'une certaine brutalité
parce que ça nous arrive dessus du jour
au lendemain je dirais que c'est
l'illusion étatique de croire que parce
qu'on va faire une obligation où on va
faire une circulaire on va régler le
problème mais ça c'est bien français
question commune madame dupont bréhat
parole merci monsieur le président je
sais que mes prises de parole agacé je
le comprends que ça fait de nombreuses
heures que nous sommes sur le sujet
après la commission la séance mais je me
permets d'intervenir une nouvelle fois
je pense que je redis je pense que il
nous faut trouver plus de souplesse à ce
texte juste très favorables aux pass and
i ter très favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire mais je ne peux pas me
résoudre à voter des articles et des
choses
qui ne sont pas applicables et réaliste
de mon point de vue donc je je redis que
tout peut pas être écrit dans la loi et
j'espère que les décrets aussi vont
amener cette souplesse mais vraiment
c'est une nécessité pour que pour que la
loi et les mesure soit effective
merci merci discussions que mène la 403
mais c'est aubert oui je crois
qu'effectivement si c'est un peu
d'ailleurs le drame de ce débat c'est à
dire que vous voulez être quelque part
dans la législation temps réel au nom de
l'efficacité mais c'est pas l'efficacité
vous devriez recherché c'est d'abord le
consensus
somme toute les représentants de
composantes de la société française
on n'est pas plus imbécile que les
autres si on vous alerte sur les
situations d'applicabilité ça n'est pas
parce que nous voulons faire de
l'opposition destructive
mais tout simplement parce que nous
sommes conscients des failles de ce que
vous proposez sauf que vous arrivez ici
avec un schéma qui a déjà été pensée qui
est déjà sorti sous forme de décret est
en nous expliquant qu'il devrait rentrer
immédiatement en vigueur
non parce que vous avez des acteurs qui
sont en plein milieu d'une saison
touristique
et ça n'est pas en le décalant de trois
semaines que vous nuire et à votre
efficacité parce qu'au contraire ça
permet travaux mesure de trouver leur
juste mesure
je vous rappelle quand même que la
devise de la république liberté égalité
fraternité dans votre affaire de passes
annie terre la liberté beaucoup de
français se demandent aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'il va en rester à partir du moment
où finalement vous avez un contrôle de
tous par tous l'égalité vous créer
simultanément deux catégories de
français avec je dirais certain qu'ils
vont faire la queue immédiatement pour
avoir des doses un manque de doses qui
va des facteurs produire des gens qui
malgré toute leur bonne volonté ne
pourront pas avoir le pass quant à la
fraternité bien je peux vous assurer
qu'avec la colère qui monte dans ce pays
la division de la société on est en
train d'atteindre exactement l'inversé
ce qu'on souhaitait réfléchir
vous dites que vous êtes en guerre mais
en réalité vous faites l'inversé ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est à dire unir
les français et donc je crois à la
limite ce serait efficace
mais même pas parce que vous le savez il
y aura pas de contrôle d'identité et
donc on est en train de fouler aux pieds
des principes qui sont les nôtres des
principes républicains pour un objectif
et résultats sanitaires qui sera
impitoyable donc voilà pourquoi je
souhaite que nous dit qu'à lyon dans le
temps un peu de souplesse montrerez
votre ouverture
monsieur le ministre madame sert 643
défendu
le suivant maj cordier le 22e défendue
et
226 du cordier défendu également chez
molac le 936 défendu 117 d'état défendu
discussion commune a été présentée j'ai
un porteur défavorable sur l'ensemble je
ministre également monsieur benoit la
parole rapidement
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en fait depuis ce matin ce
qu'on explique c'est la question de la
temporalité faut laisser du temps au
temps c'est le sens de ces amendements
la question de la complexité et la
question de l'applicabilité sur le
terrain ce que je crains réellement
monsieur le ministre c'est que celles et
ceux qui vont voter ce projet de loi
lorsqu'ils vont retourner dans leur
circonscription
ils vont passer leur temps auprès des
préfets pour demander des ajustements
pour demander des assouplissements parce
qu'on va être confronté chacune et
chacun d'entre nous dans nos territoires
a des problème d'applicabilité de mise
en oeuvre de cette loi sur le terrain la
parole merci bien monsieur le président
le départ qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est pas
un débat entre la majorité et les
oppositions le débat cet autre qu'on
entre en combat entre nos concitoyens et
le virus vous parlez de temporalité vous
deviez donner du temps est-ce que vous
pensez que le virus
louise donne de la temporalité ce qui
donne du temps donc c'est pour ça qu
effectivement il faut qu'on soit réactif
et qu'on donne un petit peu tout rond ce
qu'on se donne tous les moyens pour
effectivement lutter contre ce virus qui
lui n'a pas de temporalité merci je vais
devoir notre longue tresse décevoir
gouvernement qui est pour contre je t'ai
1113 même avis mais butt 403 identique
même avis même vote 22 mai ma vie même
vote 226 même avis même vote 966 même
avis même vote monsieur molac 975
défendu vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le président donc cet
amendement 975 donc vise à supprimer
l'obligation pour les personnels des
établissements ou le pass sanitaire rki
de devoir présenter le pass l'objectif
est notamment d'éviter une suspension
des salaires ou des licenciements pour
ses salariés
on est en train d'inventer en fait une
cause supplémentaire de licenciement
je pense que c'est particulièrement
grave et que c'est franchement pas ce
qu'il faut faire
donc j'ai demandé un scrutin public le
dessus monsieur le président merci donc
je les licenciements effectivement la
demande du scrutin public mais parvenu à
la demande de votre groupe liberté et
territoires le scrutin est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur rapporteur oui merci monsieur
président le gouvernement propose un
amendement 1033 de réécriture des
alinéas 19-21 permettant de m
place toutes les mesures à même d'éviter
un licenciement donc je renvoie le débat
à cet amendement ultérieure donc c'est
un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre est ma vie sur les
licenciements mathieu aubert oui merci
monsieur le président je crois sur cette
affaire de licenciement que on ne s'en
rend pas compte de la portée vieux de la
portée symbolique de la violence qui est
déjà cette mesure on ne peut pas mettre
dans la loi
l'idée que des gens vont perdre leur
travail dans la situation que l'on
connaît parce qu'il refuse d'être
vacciné qu'on est d'abord des sanctions
mais je veux bien entendre mais là c'est
pas une sanction
c'est une double exclusion est ce que
jean du marché du travail en plus de
l'exclusion sociale
comment si vous voulez de certains de
mes collègues qui sont dans la majorité
en marche qui ont été à gauche autrefois
au parti socialiste peuvent valider une
telle mesure
on va vous êtes devenus fous vous êtes
devenu fou et non mais vraiment surtout
quand on connaît la sensibilité du pays
à ce sujet alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous dit qu'il va y avoir un amendement
pour éviter les licenciements
la question ce n'est pas l'évitement
symbolique la question c'est qu'il faut
faire bien évidemment disparaître ce
type de menace du texte vous ne
comprendrez pas les français uniquement
par la trique
ça n'est pas possible un moment donné
c'est le civisme qui nous sauvera dans
cette crise et le civisme
vous ne rêvez pas en multipliant le
contrôle numérique ou en multipliant les
intimidations à l'égard de gens qui se
peuvent se poser des questions légitimes
par ailleurs sur la manière dont ces
vaccins sont distribués donc je bois je
regrette si vous voulez que cet
amendement soit un peu tard parce que
nous aurions besoin d'un vrai débat sur
ce sujet qui est un des points forts de
ce texte et qui pour me pour ce qui me
concerne motive notamment le vote contre
je ne voterai jamais un texte qui permet
de licencier des gens parce qu'ils
refusent de vacciner
quelle heure il
monsieur le président c'est dans la
ville
effectivement nous ne sommes pas en face
d'une mesure mineurs dans ce texte c'est
un des points centraux et vous êtes en
train de créer un nouveau motif de
licenciement
voilà finalement dans sa nudité la
brutalité des mesures que vous voulez
imposer la brutalité de cette obligation
qui ne dit pas son nom est donc
évidemment nous ne pouvons pas souscrire
à cette modification du droit du travail
qui crée un nouveau motif de
licenciement sui generis
franchement c'est profondément
inacceptable alors après ce qui va être
un peu croquignolet c'est que on va voir
ça a déjà été le cas
voir les républicains venir nous
expliquer comme ils l'ont déjà fait en
poussant votre démarche jusqu'au bout
que puisque c'est l'état qui demandent
ces licenciements et qui impose ces
licenciements ça va être à lui de les
prendre en charge donc vous allez
maintenant avoir un débat pour que
l'état finance les licenciements qui
vont être décidées dans le cadre de ce
pass sanitaires franchement je crois
qu'on peut pas aller dans cette
direction
mes chers collègues comme là il s'agit
d'un sujet majeur la création d'un
nouveau motif de licenciement jour la
discussion monsieur chiche à la parole
oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement il s'agit là de créer un
nouveau motif de licenciement en
fonction de l'état de santé ou des
traitements médicaux a suivi c'est
absolument inacceptable
on est au devant de nombreuses
difficultés les françaises et les
français soit en train de sombrer peu à
peu dans la précarité et faire ce qui
n'est ni plus ni moins que de la menace
à la perte de salaire ou à la suspension
de salaire en bref à les mettre dans
l'incapacité de subvenir à leurs besoins
et les faire tomber dans la pauvreté
parce qu'il ne souscrirait pas au pass
vaccinale c'est absolument inhumain mes
chers collègues qu'est ce qui va se
passer quand on va expliquer à une
personne que tu allais suspendu de son
emploi que son salaire est suspendu nous
avons des personnes qui n'auront plus
aucune ressource pour vivre qui ne
pourront plus émarger à l'assurance
chômage
de fait ils seront simplement situation
de suspension de rémunération et de
missions dans leur travail
je pense que c'est d'un cynisme absolu
de faire du chantage à l'emploi de la
menace à la précarité et à la pauvreté
à la crise sanitaire nous ne pouvons pas
ajouter une menace permanente sur
l'affaiblissement de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyens merci
madame vient te demander la parole puis
madame t-il merci monsieur le président
il y à un moment donné il vaut mieux
dire aux français il y à un variant qui
est dangereux nous souhaitons vous
protéger et nous mettons l'obligation
vaccinale en place dans notre pays parce
que la diro personnes si vous ne vous
vacciner pas vous perdez votre boulot je
ne sais pas comment vous appelez ça mais
une personne qui perd son travail pour
faute lourde qui n'auront qu'une
indemnité qui perdra tous ses droits
vous appelez ça comment c'est soit tu te
vaccine soit tu perds tes droits ton
emploi et ton âge
et on sait pas comment tu vas manger à
la fin du mois comment vous appelez ça
et après vous nous dites ah non non non
on n'oblige personne non mais un pass
and it et c'est ça la défiance que vous
mettez en place dans notre pays et qu'on
essaye de vous expliquer depuis deux
jours vous ne pouvez pas et moi je vais
vous parler d'une amie fab vous l'avez
obligé contrainte à se vacciner moi je
peux vous dire que j'ai vu le soir de
son vaccin
j'ai jamais vu aussi énervé et c des
personnes qui croyaient en la science en
la médecine et tout ça et qui maintenant
va tout regarder dès qu'elle va perdre
un cheveu trop dès que ma soeur me dit
ça va être à cause du vaccin mais parce
que il faut rendre confiance et vous
êtes quand même assez marrant sur ses
bancs parce que c'est facile de
contraindre les gens disant vaccinez
vous vous serez virés mais alors quand
il s'agit de contraindre les labos est
transparent y a personne
merci monsieur le président nous sommes
en train de parler du licenciement
d'employés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le pass sanitaire
est ce qu'on est bien au courant est
conscient de ce qu'on fait de licencier
de rendre chez eux sans indemnité sans
rien sans travail sans revenus des gens
qui n'ont que ça pour vivre parce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu présenter un pass
sanitaires je ne sais pas comment ici on
peut signer oui je rends les gens au
chômage même pas au chômage
je rends les gens à à la vie sans rien
je ne peux pas signer de quoi rendre les
gens ni de quoi les licenciés
mathieu david merci monsieur le
président qui dans ce gouvernement a pu
avoir une telle idée qui a pu imaginer
qui a pu imaginer qu'en menaçant les
gens on allait les contraindre
mais qui à notre époque en 2021 peut
imaginer que la france peut fonctionner
comme ça imaginez ce pays de liberté
quand même qu que vous remettez en cause
et surtout parmi les catégories en
faisant de véritable injustice
lorsque vous traitez les fonctionnaires
de manière différente selon qu'ils
soient policiers ou professeurs selon
qu'ils soient gendarmes aux juges mais
mais mais vous vous avez vous passé
vraiment à côté de toute humanité
possible
[Musique]
oui il va nous répondre le ministre va
nous répondre que non parce que lui il
est tout à fait alors je me demande les
convictions qu'il pouvait avoir
lorsqu'il était au parti socialiste
merci monsieur viguier
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre à avoir raison cela relève tine
de la seule appartenance à une majorité
on assiste sur ce texte à la posture
d'une majorité qui n'écoutent pas les
propositions d'une opposition qui ne
fait que remonter
les témoignages du terrain chers
collègues en quoi vos circonscriptions
sont elles différentes des nôtres
que vous disent les professionnels et
les habitants de vos territoires
cette histoire du pass sanitaire divise
le pays c'est au fond l'histoire d'une
vaccination obligatoire qui ne dit pas
son nom
le contrat de confiance n'est pas au
rendez vous de la gestion de cette crise
finalement le seul inconvénient du
vaccin serait qu'il devienne obligatoire
alors nous ne voulons pas je ne veux pas
pour ma part refusé la seule protection
efficace qu'il constitue merci alors
monsieur le ministre à la parole
je suis très surpris mais surprise donc
le débat sur cette question là aient
lieu à cet endroit du texte parce que
l'alinéa qui traitent des modalités de
rupture de contrat en cas de non respect
du texte c'est effectivement la guinée à
partir de l'année à 19
l'amendement qui est défendu par
monsieur molac entraîne ceci suppression
pure et simple du pas salutaire pour
tous les salariés des établissements
recevant du public
c'est ça qui veut dire l'amendement donc
on allait au delà monsieur le président
vous avez il ya un débat qui s'est
organisée autour de la question des
conditions de madame est donné sur la
façon de faire respecter le passe à
lithaire ce n'est pas ce que dit
l'amendement ce n'est pas la bonne
position
non non non ce n'est pas la bonne
position dans le texte donc je veux
doigt par honnêteté de prendre la parole
pour pouvoir le dire moi même ce n'est
pas ce que dit cet amendement s'agissant
puisque maintenant monsieur président
nous avons eu le débat peut-être que
nous ne l'aurons - tout à l'heure
j'imagine sur les bons alinéa et les
bons amendements
le gouvernement présentera effectivement
un amendement de réécriture des
dispositions ou very qui n'est en aucun
cas question de licencier du jour au
lendemain quelqu'un qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés une enquête du pas de
sanitaires je présenterai je présenterai
le mot je présenterai cet amendement qui
est 2033 le moment venu est vrai que
toutes les mesures d'accompagnement
voulait que je lis je peux le dire
maintenant si vous voulez mais c'est on
va avoir un débat 5 alinéa avant qu'on
en aura ce soir donc je pense que
voulait que je le dise maintenant
[Musique]
moi je peux plus tard dont trois
permanents mes chers collègues nous
écoutons le ministre nous évitera le
débat un peu plus tard les aigles autant
ministre donc ce n'est encore une fois
pas l'amendement sur lequel vous allez
voter l'amendement sur lequel vous avez
tram n'a voté par scrutin public c'est
la suppression du pass à lithaire pour
les salariés des rpr recevant du public
je redis maintenant
l'amendement qui sera présenté par le
gouvernement tout à leur dit que qui se
traitent de l'article pour objet de
préciser les conséquences sur la
relation professionnelle du refus de
présentation du pass sanitaire des
personnes soumises à cette obligation en
fonction de leur statut de salarié ou
d'agents publics
il permet de restaurer un dialogue entre
l'employeur et chaque agent public ou
salariés pour faciliter le recours aux
passes sanitaires et de tout mettre en
oeuvre afin de régulariser la situation
par rapport à cette nouvelle obligation
et ainsi éviter de mettre fin à ses
fonctions ou son contrat de travail
ouais on est déjà dans quelque chose qui
est plus souple ainsi le présente
amendement prévoit la possibilité de
poser des congés le temps d'effectuer
les démarches nécessaires prendre des
congés et le temps d'effectuer les
démarches nécessaires c'est à dire de se
faire vacciner lorsque ce n'est pas
terminé de suspendre les fonctions ou le
contrat pendant une durée d'au moins
deux mois et d'examiner les possibilités
de reclassement sur un autre poste on
est assez loin du licenciement sec s'ils
n'avaient pas le pas solitaire à l'heure
dite
à l'issue d'un délai de deux mois la
possibilité pour l'employeur d'engager
une procédure de radiation des cadres ou
de licenciement est ouverte
selon des modalités spécifiques et
adaptées aux différentes populations
concernées attendait quant au camp quand
on dit monsieur le député qu'on applique
le pass sanitaires aux salariés des
établissements recevant du public
je suis j'ai été député ya pas si
longtemps que ça je crois connaître que
pour chaque devoir il ya des
conséquences en cas de non respect ou
alors ça veut dire qu'on s'est fait
plaisir qu'on a mis un pas salutaire qui
se passe rien là je vous dis juste qu'on
est très loin des positions outrancière
que j'ai entendu dans certaines
interventions disant qu'on manquerait
d'humanité qu'on avait viré tout le
monde sait absolument pas dangereux et
je vous dire ma conviction ça n'arrivera
pas parce que vu le nombre de demandes
de vaccination que nous enregistrons
depuis quelques jours et qui vont se
poursuivre pendant toute la période à
venir
pendant toute la période à venir le
passe à lithaire le pass and i ter sera
respectée par l'ensemble des salariés de
ce pays
je vais je ne partage pas les
inquiétudes et encore moins les procès
en d'humanité
quant à vous monsieur le député
socialiste oui j'ai siégé sur ses bancs
j'étais très fière et j'étais très fier
de défendre des positions parfois
courageuse qui n'allait pas tout le
temps dans le sens du vent mais c'est
ainsi et c'est peut-être pour ça que je
me retrouve aujourd'hui dans cette
majorité
alors monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je n'ai pas du tout
interpréter loin de moi monsieur le
ministre nous propos comme une remise en
cause de la présidence mais il se trouve
que cet amendement prévoit la
suppression des halles ignares 19 et 20
qui envisageait un dispositif de
licenciement donc c'est tout à fait
légitime que les uns et les autres ce
soir et évoquer ces sujets c'est tout à
fait normal et ça me paraît très
légitime que nous ouvrions un déballage
quand on ouvre une nourrice que les
licenciements
si on avait été dans un débat de droit
du travail on aurait pris une journée là
dessus un monsieur n'à qu'à la parole
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président parce
que quand on lit la linea 19 il est
quand même très clair lorsqu'une
personne à laquelle les mesures
mentionnées aux 1 et 2 s'appliquent ne
présente pas les justificatifs
certificats aux résultats dans ces
dispositions lui impose la présentation
son employeur lui notifie par tous
moyens la suspension de ses fonctions ou
de son contrat de travail
cette suspension qui s'accompagne de
l'interruption du versement de la
rémunération prend fin dès que l'un
l'intéressé produits les justificatifs
nécessaires cette décision lui est
notifié le jour même par tous moyens ça
veut bien dire qu'effectivement un
employeur peut vous licenciez sur cet
acte là
alors tous les groupes qui le
souhaitaient ont pu s'exprimer y compris
les non inscrits le groupe en marche ne
s'est pas exprimé c'est tout à fait
légitime madame dubois que vous
exprimiez merci alors je voudrais je
voudrais comme l'a fait le ministre
remettre les choses à leur place je
personnellement j'ai déposé à l'article
21 qui tombera peut-être mais un
amendement qui ne permet pas qui ne qui
ne permet pas de licencier
l'alinéa parvint pas dans l'alinéa 20e
merci merci beaucoup mais dense dans
l'alinéa 14
il est question du pass sanitaire n'est
pas question d'une licenciement donc on
est à l'heure on est à l'heure nous
sommes en train
l'amendement de monsieur mollahs qui est
disposée et à les déposer à l'alinéa 14
et l'ont même du bois c'est totalement
faux à risque concerne maintenant que
nous avons voté prévoit la suppression
des allocs distinctive un don donc c'est
leur manager ratenon la mode si on veut
que la line et si on vote l'amendement
de monsieur molac en supprime le pass
pour les minimes 19 et 20 et lober le
pass et le pass
alors donc monsieur monsieur molac a pu
s'exprimer
donc chacun des groupes alors un rappel
au règlement parce que votre groupe
s'est exprimée m6 a donc pas de propos
sur le fond on est d'accord mais merci
monsieur prison c'est pas un propos sur
le fond c'est juste pour dire pour la
clarté de nos débats l'amendement
prévoit de supprimer la fin de la linea
14 supprimer la linea 19
l'alinéa 20 l'alinéa 21 voilà comme ça
on est tous sur le même niveau
d'information je crois l'avoir dit déjà
un chômeur n'est si simple
nous allons maintenant voter chacun a pu
regagner sa place c'est un vote
électronique il a été annoncé
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici les résultats
votre sens d'y exprimer 158 majorité 80
pour 71 contre 87 l'amendement n'est
donc pas adoptée
madame dubois faisait la parole sur les
480 de défendu défavorable commission
gouvernement je vais vous voyez pour
contre je t'ai monsieur peru de 420
n'ont pas défendu le 213e monsieur d'art
évident
le président est donc il s'agit d'un
amendement qui
souhaite décaler l'application du passo
15 septembre afin de laisser le temps à
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens de
pouvoir engager les démarches attendu
par ce texte
ça n'empêche pas que nous y restons
opposés mais il s'agit de véritablement
donner le temps de la mise en
application et le 1er août évidemment il
sera trop tôt pour que tous ceux qui le
souhaitent pour celles qui le souhaitent
puissent engager ses démarches
merci identique le 419 mais il n'est pas
défendu avis de la commission sur un
docteur défavorable ses ministres
défavorable chérubins oui la vente
l'avant demande déposée par le collègue
pierre dharréville il est récurrent il a
été déposée à peu près de la même
manière sur les bancs de la droite et à
aucun moment le gouvernement vient nous
expliquer comment concrètement ça à
pouvoir être mis en oeuvre
puisque l'âge les témoignages qu'on
recueille nous disent qu'il va falloir
des semaines parfois pour avoir le
rendez-vous que ensuite il faut avoir la
deuxième dose que ensuite ya encore une
semaine qui se passe ça veut dire que
quand bien même les gens se déciderait
maintenant c'est pas avant si cette
semaine qu'ils pourront être dans les
clous
qu'est ce qu'on fait pendant ce laps de
temps là il est évident que c'est un
amendement un minimum de bon sens de
dire que ce pass sanitaires il doit être
décalé pour permettre aux gens de
continuer à vivre de continuer à
travailler
et là il n'y a pas de réponse du
gouvernement ceux là dessus alors que ça
fait maintenant des dizaines de fois
qu'il a été interpellé
je vais donc voie d'amendement 213 qui
est pour contre rejeté
le 512 madame battistel oui merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
vise également à décaler dans le temps
l'application de se passe de la même
manière que nous l'avons proposé pour le
passé ni terre d'autant que les
conséquences peuvent être les
conséquences sociales et économiques
peuvent être importantes et graves pour
les personnes donc nous proposons un
décalage au 1er octobre 2021 pour ses
personnels merci alors c'est une
discussion comme une leçon 73 qui le
défend monsieur dekker défendu jeudi
philippe hall 9 58
oui certainement vraiment encore une
fois un amendement de bon sens comprenez
bien les choses vous demandez aux
salariés de drp d'avoir complété leur
parcours vaccinale avant le 30 août
même pour les salariés des personnels
les personnels soignants
c'est le 15 septembre vous comprenez
bien que ces salariés là d'ici au 30
août ils ne peuvent pas compléter un
parcours vaccinale complet avoir un pass
center pour pouvoir travailler décemment
c'est ce que propose cet amendement
c'est juste de passer du 30 août au 30
septembre
on ne parle pas de personnel soignant on
parle de personnels qui travaillent dans
des dents des dents des rp vous allez au
devant de grands grands difficulté
penser à notre économie en ce moment
tous les chefs d'entreprise que vous
voyez qu est-ce qui vous disent on
n'arrive pas à recruter
on a du boulot on n'arrive pas à
recruter vous allez encore créer des
difficultés à leurs salariés
vraiment là-dessus que vous demande
juste ce simple geste monsieur le
ministre qui me paraît être une évidence
les 56 madame antoine défendu le champ
monsieur reiss est en émoi les
contraintes doivent être les mêmes pour
tous ceux 12 cet amendement de madame
grenier ça donnez moi monsieur des
coeurs à nouveau samedi défendue mme
monsieur dharréville défendu lé 223
madame chapelier nom ahmed chapelier
vous étiez l'apd à l'heure c'est pour ça
madame chapeau lire les paroles
merci monsieur le président c'est donc
un amendement de cohérence pour que dans
ce texte il y au moins de date qui
coïncide merci madame nouvelle ville ce
4,9 oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement il s'agit de donner du
temps au temps puisque effectivement
nous avons aujourd'hui des temps pour
s'inscrire pour la vaccination
nous avons par ailleurs un temps entre
la première injection et la seconde
injection
et vous avez refusé monsieur le ministre
et nos collègues de la majorité
d'inscrire les primo vaccinant comme
pouvant bénéficier du pass sanitaire
dans ce qu'on vous propose à travers cet
amendement c'est de laisser du temps et
de ne pas finalement piégé les français
parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement ils
sont piégés ne peuvent pas accéder au
pass sanitaires dans les délais
contraints de du dispositif que vous
proposez donc effectivement c'est de
leur laisser du temps pour éviter que ce
que les français soient piégés 90 me
j'ai défendu le savent sans chanter 11
n'est pas défendu
pas défendu me tue benassaya 925
oui mais ce président merci on a dit
donc le processus vaccinale en france
demande un certain temps soit à cause du
manque de doses comme cela a été le cas
durant plusieurs longues semaines soit
parce que le délai entre les deux
injections nécessaires avec six nations
est conséquent sachant que la
vaccination des 18 40 a été ouverte le
29 mai dernier qu'il faut compter quatre
à six semaines entre les deux nous
écoutons notre ventaja un thé ou verte
le 29 mai donc dernier je disais qu'il
faut compter quatre à six semaines entre
les deux doses
on ne peut pas exiger que toute cette
population qui représente plus de 15
millions d'individus soit on la dit
vacciner d'ici le 30 août
par exemple dans le département des
yvelines dont je suis élu
près de cent trente mille personnes
attendent leur deuxième dose de vaccin
et seront donc pénalisé par la mise en
vigueur du pass le 30 août dans les
lieux prévus par la ligne a14 alors la
non vaccination étant peu contraignantes
jusqu aux annonces du président de la
république
les personnes ayant été incités à se
faire vacciner à partir de maintenant
nous aurons reçu la totalité de leurs
doses au plus tôt mi août
il est donc cohérent de laisser comment
lundi plus de temps aux français pour
organiser leur vaccination
sachant que les vacances d'été
contraignent évidemment les avis du des
individus qui ne sont plus sur leur lieu
de résidence
cet amendement dont vise à déplacer la
mise en vigueur du pass sanitaire au 15
septembre merci merci monsieur le
président je propose de décaler
également l'application du pass
sanitaire au 1er septembre alors
premiers symptômes 30 août au 1er
septembre vous allez me dire ça change
pas grand chose
pourquoi ces deux jours tout simplement
parce que je les dis depuis hier le
principal défaut de votre projet de loi
c'est son manque de lisibilité et
harmoniser toutes les dates toutes les
dates au 1er septembre
ça aurait le mérite de la clarté sauver
le mérite de la clarté parce que je
voulais dit les français n'y comprennent
plus rien il ya des dispositions qui
sont entrées en vigueur hier
il y en a d'autres qui vont entrer en
vigueur au 1er août d'autres encore au
30 août
d'autres encore au 15 septembre et puis
d'autres encore au 30 septembre
comment voulez vous que les français s'y
retrouve alors le 1er septembre
peut-être c'est pas la bonne date
peut-être il faut en trouver une autre
mais au moins je pense que ça à la
mairie
de laisser passer l'été ça mérite d'être
facile à retenir par tous et ça
correspond à la rentrée scolaire ça le
mérite au moins de la clarté de la
lisibilité de la loi je vous remercie
mais ces rapporteurs défavorable
monsieur le ministre défavorable à la
parole oui on à diverses théories du
temps qui existe un il ya le temps ait
jeté mien le temps bachelard dhien le
temps mc est maintenant on a le temps
mac rognan on a une réinvention de
l'espace temps où voilà que en quelques
jours alors qu'on sait qu'il va falloir
quelques semaines il ya des millions de
personnes dont on sait qu'ils ne
rentreront pas dans les clous de ce
dispositif mais c'est pas grave la loi
viendrait produire un nouvel espace
temps ça a l'air drôle comme ça mais je
pense qu'il faut mesurer la rage que
vous risquez de déclencher la rage que
vous risquez de déclencher c'est chez
ceux qui ne veulent pas rentrer là
dedans mais la rage que je vous risquez
déclenché aussi chez ceux qui n'auront
pas de rendez-vous attend la rage chez
ceux qui ne seront pas dans les clous
attend la rage sur ce qu'ils vont
risquer un licenciement
et tout ça pour presser tout pressé dans
un calendrier dont il ya aucune
explication du gouvernement sur comment
il va pouvoir être tenu vous savez qu'il
n'est pas tenable et pourtant vous
pensez que parce que ça va être votée ça
va rentrer dans les faits mais les bulls
à rentrera pas dans les faits jamais aux
voileux 512 défavorable commission pour
ne manquer pour contre jeter le centre
est identique pour contre je t'ai 56 est
identique même avis même vote de 500 750
d'un feed antique mais ma vie même vote
le jury fera le 1089
il était il est aidé en 1089 jury fin
pas mais super ça marche ça marche ça
marche
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
le président ce qui se passe là
discrètement dans la moiteur de l'été en
une fin d'après midi
c'est un dollar c'est un bouleversement
dans le code du travail
vous l'avez dit normalement les
dispositions sur lesquelles on est en
train de statuer là on devrait en
discuter pendant des jours
tellement ça bouleverse le rapport
employant employés c'est ce que signale
un avocat en droit du travail
dans un papier du figaro les salariés ne
doivent pas être contraints de matt
raymond très impasse sanitaires pour
train pour travailler le parlement
semble s'apprêter à voter sans scrupules
un texte qui fait pourtant volé en éclat
un principe fondamental du droit du
travail et bien un minimale à ce qu'on
demande c'est que pour les salariés de
la restauration n'est pas cette
obligation là d'autant qu'on sait qu'ils
arriveront pas avoir un rendez-vous
attend que il leur faudra des semaines
de passes sannitz de peu de change sur
le passé ni terre à jour et vous le
savez je vous le redis mesurer la rage
que ça va pouvoir produire chez des
salariés qui vont vivre une situation
d'inquiétude en situation de danger
le risque d'être licenciée parce que ils
rentrent répondent pas à vos injonctions
alors que c'est impossible aujourd'hui
d'y répondre le 15
[Musique]
il défendu pas défendu le 282 me pas
défendu le 677 descendu à vis de la
commission défavorable monsieur le
ministre est favorable mais c'est le
président mélenchon à la parole
collègues ministres collègues
c'est vraiment un vote où je vois bien
que peut-être qu'on ne se comprend pas
beaucoup d'entre vous exprime à ce sujet
une préoccupation de type sanitaires et
j'ai pas l'intention de diminuer la
qualité de vos intentions sur le sujet
mais prenez bien la mesure de ce que
nous sommes en train de décider
le contrat de travail est le seul
contrat qui prévoit dans une démocratie
comme la nôtre c'est le seul qui prévoit
un rapport de subordination entre une
personne et une autre je ne lance pas la
discussion de savoir si c'est juste ou
si ça ne l'est pas mais ce rapport de
subordination est entièrement liée à la
nature de la tâche à opérer et du
rapport salarial vous y ajouter une
clause sociale ce qui veut dire que la
subordination du travailleur et non
seulement lié au fait qu'il est le
travailleur qui ne possèdent pas
l'instrument de production mais en plus
que son corps que sa santé est
directement liée à l'exercice de ce
qu'il est en train de faire et bien ça
c'est une nouveauté d'une telle ampleur
qu'elle mériterait qu'on s'y arrête plus
longuement qu'on est en train de le
faire j'ajoute ceci vous savez aussi
bien que moi que c'est un acte
totalement arbitraire qui peut découler
des dispositions qui sont prises
pourquoi parce qu'il suffirait que
pierre paul ou jacques n'ai pas obtenu à
temps son certificat de vaccination qui
ne soit pas efficace dans les délais
prévus pour qu'il perde son emploi
collègue est ce que vous imaginez
l'ampleur de l'angoissent de l'anxiété
de la déstabilisation sociale familiale
affective qu'une telle mesure
entraîne dans la vie quotidienne des
gens comment pouvez vous être assez
cruel pour décider une chose pareille
sachant que si l'organisation mondiale
de la santé l'organisation mondiale de
la santé dont vous prétendez est acquis
vous prétendez être supérieure en
intelligence de situation vous dis qu'il
faut donner la liberté plutôt que
l'obligation vous introduisez dans le
code du travail une violation de la
liberté supplément m'ériger président
monsieur j mais la parole
[Applaudissements]
bon la droite se préoccupe des
employeurs et d'ailleurs il ya des
éléments de complexité qui justifie sa
permettez qu'on se préoccupe des
salariés à travers la mesure proposée en
instaurant la possibilité de licencier
pour des personnes non vaccinées vous
remettez en cause d'une manière abrupte
unilatérale une clause substantielle
d'un contrat de travail qui justifie un
licenciement nous content d'avoir
flinguer le droit du travail vous
rajoutez désormais un nouvel argument un
nouveau motif de licenciement qui fera
l'objet de barémisation d'indemnisation
et qui aura les drames humains les
drames sociaux que nous disons ce
faisant vous refuser de prendre en
compte une réalité sociale qu'on
développe depuis plusieurs heures
c'est que nous considérons que les gens
qui refusent le vaccin pour des raisons
idéologiques sont minoritaires ceux qui
ne sont pas encore vaccinés sont des
personnes qu'il faut convaincre pour
qu'il faut développer déployer un plan
vaccinal au plus proche pour leur
permettre de rentrer dans cette aventure
bah oui ne gérait déjà dit mais comme
vous entendez pas je le redis d'accord
et ben alors voter nos amendements si
vous entendez est donc là nous avons
l'illustration de la posture autoritaire
de la trique de du bâton agité par les
libéraux que vous êtes qui évidemment
décide de taper toujours sur les mêmes
les plus faibles c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposons
renoncer à cette mauvaise idée qui deux
sur trois va poser des problèmes y
compris en termes de recrutement de
déséquilibre des entreprises concernées
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
propose puisque vous entendez nos
arguments et bien de mélanger cette
écoute en votant les amendements jamais
devoir d'abord le 1080i gouvernement qui
est pour contre jeter le 670 ce qui est
pur contre rejeté de 210 madame avia
telle 1 217 il défendu pas défendu le
468 scellé même pas défendu madame
ménard le 63 défendu monsieur rapporteur
monsieur me disent défavorables
je suis pradier merci monsieur le
président sur cette question du
licenciement
je pense que le plus grand monsieur le
ministre c'est que vous et le
gouvernement vous faites totalement
fausse route vous trompez ce que vous
êtes en train d'installer sera
inefficace pour une raison simple c'est
que par ce type de mesure là vous tuer
ce qui est le bien le plus précieux en
matière de santé publique pas les
différentes mesures non le bien le plus
précieux c'est la confiance et vous
faites totalement fausse route en
imaginant que par cette menace là que
par cette contrainte là vous allez
pousser certaines nos concitoyens
réticents à la vaccination
et c'est la première erreur fondamentale
que vous commettez de supposer que par
cette contrainte de la jusqu'au boutiste
vous allez pousser des femmes et des
hommes à la vaccination
vous allez créer une fracturation dans
la société une rupture de confiance qui
ira au delà même de celles et ceux qui
sont concernés
la réalité c'est que parmi nos
concitoyens depuis plusieurs jours ils
sont nombreux à être vaccinés tout à
fait favorable à la vaccination et à
être opposés à cette mesure là vous
nourrissez avec cette ce type de mesures
un climat de confiance
votre de un climat de défiance
votre deuxième faute votre ce votre
seconde faute monsieur le ministre c'est
d'être borgne et le soleil qui vous
restent y voit mal vous ne voyez qu avec
l'oeil des mesures sanitaires
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
sujet vous n'y voyez pas très vous n'y
voyez pas très claire sur les masques
que vous n'y voyez pas très claire par
le passé sur le pass vaccinale non plus
et sur la stratégie vaccinale non plus
mais vous oubliez de regarder avec un
autre oeil qui est nécessaire lorsqu'on
est ministre de la république c'est
celui du respect de nos principes
fondamentaux
vous êtes en train de toucher à un
élément substantiel des relations de
travail de nos concitoyens et cet
élément là il fera jurisprudence
ne nous dites pas que c'est pas vrai il
y a quelques semaines vous nous disiez
que sur le pas si nate est sanitaire il
n'y aurait pas d'avenir et aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train de le voter
ces deux fautes la rupture de commenter
en 6 et l'affaiblissement de nos
principes sont des fautes graves jamais
de 23 des femmes j'aurais manqué pour
contre rejeté monsieur rufin à 1092
je les dis en ouverture des débats mais
moi je préférerais qu'on ait un débat
franc sur l'obligation vaccinale pour
toute la population
plutôt que de l'avoir par tranches je
suis contre je suis pour la liberté
vaccinale
comme l'a déclaré le président de la
république au début il se trouve que je
moi je n'ai pas changé d'avis comme vous
étiez tous pour la liberté vaccinale au
début et comme depuis vous avez tous
changer d'avis avec des playmobil qui se
range derrière les désirs du président
et quand le président et liberté
vaccinale vous viennent de mener tous
nous dire liberté vaccinale
quand le président dit obligation venez
tous nous dire obligations mais je
préférerais qu'on ait ce débat franc
plutôt que de prendre le truc par
tranches et de deer valley les salariés
de la restauration doivent se vacciner
les salariés des hôpitaux doit se
vacciner ou là les salariés des centres
commerciaux doivent se vacciner il ya un
an ont salué les caissières on estimait
que en deuxième ligne
pendant le confinement elle avait permis
la continuité des activités de la nation
que les gens continuent à s'alimenter et
les mêmes que vous aviez salué les
dernières sur kelly et rien gagner
puisqu'elle continue à être immédiat
éliminé par des plans sociaux laurent
dans les centres commerciaux mais les
mêmes aujourd'hui vont être menacés de
licenciement par la loi que vous mettez
en place
donc évidemment on souhaite que lle elle
soit préservée et que les caissières les
autres employés de l'art de des centres
commerciaux soit pas que cette
vaccination défavorable commission
défavorable gouvernement je vais devoir
qui est pour contre rejeté le 429 n'est
pas défendue m 2 le 271e monsieur damien
adam sinon c'est un moment ils visent à
revenir sur la date d'application du
pass sanitaires notamment pour la
tranche d'âge des 18 55 ans parce que
paul est de plus de 55 ans il n'y a pas
de sujet particulier puisque pour le
coup
la vaccination a été ouverte pour ce
public depuis de nombreux mois mais pour
les moins de 55 ans il faut rappeler
qu'elle n'a été ouverte que le 30 mai
dernier avec à l'époque un délai de
trente cinq jours entre les deux doses
auxquelles il faut rajouter un délai de
15 jours pour avoir un pass sanitaire
validé et donc à une forme d'injustice à
faire en sorte que ce pas sanitaire
s'applique à ce public à partir du 1er
août c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle pour les mineurs nous avons
voté en commission un amendement qui
repousse cette date d'application
au 30 septembre il ya bien une période
de rodage qui a été annoncé par le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent
de sept jours mais je pense qu'il serait
nécessaire pour ce public très
particulier des 18 55 ans de prendre en
considération le fait que la vaccination
a été ouverte plus tard et donc de
repousser l'application du pass
sanitaires pour ce public de 15 jours
seulement pour l'amener au 15 août
je vous remercie merci monsieur monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur ministre
également défavorable sur des forums du
ministre je mets donc voilà mandement 2
enchanté ondes qui est pour et qui est
contre
alors qui est pour
les contres oui dont il est rejeté à
jeter discussion commune 450 et à
monsieur d'art évident
madame madame le bon pari
merci monsieur le président alors on va
revenir sur le débat intérieur extérieur
on sait jamais sur un malentendu ça peut
marcher
cet amendement vise à prévoir
expressément que l'obligation de
présenter un pass and i ter ne
s'applique pas aux activités en
extérieur comme le font la majorité des
pays européens
parce que le risque de transmission du
virus est plus faible à l'extérieur donc
nous considérons que s'y passe
sanitaires il doit y avoir
les activités en extérieur devrait ne
pas être subordonnée à la présentation
d'un pass sanitaires merci merci
discussion commune 70 ce monsieur div
défendue je manquais défendu un monsieur
meyer pardonnez moi voulait défendre et
la parole je m'avoue est cosignataire
oui tout à fait vrai la parole merci
monsieur le président effectivement dans
la prolongation de ce qui vient d'être
dit il est clair que les éléments
scientifiques que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui plutôt bien met clairement
en avant que les transmissions ne se
fait que très faiblement à l'extérieur à
l'exception bien entendu des
rassemblements ou les personnes
s'agglutinent donc il est proposé dans
cet amendement d'exclure l'application
du pass sanitaires dans les activités
qui sont dans ces zones extérieures
à partir du moment les distances à sion
sociales sont respectées merci messieurs
à porter défavorable geminis défavorable
j'aimais ouvre successivement ces
amendements 451 qui est pour contre
rejeté 70 pour contre je t'ai discussion
commune 734 monsieur baker le mil 5016
n'est pas défendu toujours discussion
commune le
le onze des pas défendu madame lemoine
défendu sur cette série défavorable sur
l'ensemble jeu mais monsieur ministre
également
je mets au voile 734 identique est pour
quand rejeté le
le twr 83 identique et même avis même
vote mme genevard le 8 septembre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la président de la commission
des lois
on est très interpellé par les maires en
ce moment pour savoir si les petites
manifestations de villages qui sont
organisés peuvent se tenir
et là nous sommes sous le coup du décret
qui est paru le 21
et quand on demande au préfet comment il
interprète le décret pour savoir si
telle ou telle manifestation peut se
tenir
la réponse est imprécise non pas par
manque de professionnalisme mais parce
que il est difficile d'établir une
doctrine en la matière et la réponse
intermédiaires qui a été donné est la
suivante soit vous êtes en capacité de
contrôler l'accès à l'espace où se
développe la manifestation et dans ce
cas là vous demandez le pass sanitaire
soit vous n'êtes pas en capacité parce
que l'espace n'est pas clos et dans ce
cas là vous ne contrôlez pas alors moi
je suis quand même
interrogé par cette réponse et je
voudrais savoir monsieur le ministre
quel et quelle précision vous pouvez
nous apporter parce que les mères nous
demandent les responsables associatifs
nous interroge et on est bien en peine
de leur répondent précisément sur ce
point
donc merci monsieur le ministre de
clarifier la position du gouvernement le
rapporteur défendra ses ministres
défavorable également monsieur chez les
bergers à la parole
tcn berger la parole monsieur le
ministre ne me surprend pas que vous ne
répondiez pas la question précise posée
par madame genevard pourquoi parce que
c'est cette imprécision qui vous a
permis de rompre avec la volonté qui
était celle exprimée par l'assemblée
nationale lorsqu'elle a créé le pass
sanitaire en mai dernier
et lorsque l'assemblée nationale a créé
le pass sanitaire en mai dernier on
disait c'est pas pour la vie courante
c'est pas pour l'extérieur sauf pour les
grands rassemblements comme les
festivals ou autre
qu'est ce que vous en avez fait de cette
règle et de ses principes qui était
pourtant clair et qui avait fait
consensus dans notre hémicycle
vous en avez fait le décret qui est
sorti hier où vous dites c'est 50
personnes et c'est tous les éléments de
la vie courante sauf ce qui vous est
vraiment interdit par la loi qu'on avait
voté dans celle qui vous ai suggéré
aujourd'hui vous allez pouvoir demander
le pass annie terre pour absolument tout
pour tous pour circuler dans la rue vous
allez pouvoir trouver une astuce pour
demander le pass sanitaires et c'est
bien pour ça c'est bien pour ça que
depuis deux jours on vous demande des
précisions
on vous demande de vous engager à vous
en tenir à l'esprit et pas seulement à
la lettre parce que ce que vous allez
faire c'est maximiser maximiser au plus
ce qui est dans ce texte
et à la fin c'est contrôlé en permanence
en tout lieu en tout moment les français
sur leur smartphone leur papier ça va
devenir invivable
merci monsieur le ministre d'état paul
je sais pas que vous répondre on n'est
peut-être pas dans le même monde
bâtiment
monsieur le député ce qui est pardon
excusez moi chacun est libre 1 mais
j'avais cru comprendre que pendant la
consultation des groupes politiques par
le premier ministre le pass sanitaires
avaient plutôt eu un écho favorable de
la part de votre groupe alors je ne sais
pas où sont les parlementaires qui de au
sein de l air y était favorable
mais manifestement ne s'exprime que ceux
qui sont contre c'est tellement plus
simple comme ça on a le beurre pour dire
aux français qu'on est pour parce que
les français sont pour et l'argent du
beurre parce qu'on vient donner des
leçons de la majorité dans l'hémicycle
jour et nuit
je sais pas je sais pas si vous recevez
le même message que moi mais je n'ai
rare j'ai rarement reçu autant de
messages via les réseaux sociaux via mon
mail ou un sms de français qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils s'inquiètent à
l'idée que l'on finisse par ne pas
pouvoir mettre en place le pass à iter
pour les protéger j'imagine que chacun
chacun reçoit ses propres messages mais
je voulais juste vous prévenir que juste
que je reçois je crois que les débats
sont très regardé donc bref même se
faire excuser moi j'ai eu une seconde
d'absence ça peut arriver
il ya 1200 amendements je suis là je
fais des jours les nuits avec vous c'est
un vrai bonheur jeu mais c'est vrai
c'est un vrai bonheur partagé j'espère
je me fais le mini hurler dessus depuis
des jours et des jours par une poignée
de députés qui viennent et qui s'en vont
mal amusé à 9 heures vous ne faites pas
partie de ceux là je suis très heureux
de vous répondre
vous posez la question de savoir comment
s'appelait j'ai compris c'est un
amendement d'appel pour savoir comment
s'appliquerait le pass sanitaires dans
les fêtes de village
le padd sanitaires dans les fêtes de
village est un décret c'est d'articles
47-1 du décret du 1er juin 2021 qui
décrit les choses le pass à lithaire ne
peut s'appliquer dans le cas de fête de
village que pour les activités qui sont
susceptibles de donner lieu à des
contrôles donc le décret n'a dit les
préfets ont confirmé que ce serait le
sens de l'application c'est à dire que
si on est dans une fête diffuse de
village ou avec dans les rues et cetera
ce n'est pas susceptible de donner lieu
à un contrôle
si en revanche la fête est focalisée
dans un endroit donné que ce soit en
indoor ou en extérieur et en intérieur
ou en extérieur avec des activités qui
donne lieu à des filtrations parce que
c'est déjà la coutume est bien ou pour
des raisons de sécurité alors il peut
être demandé le passé ni terre donc tout
est écrit dans le décret et ça n'a
soulevé aucune objection de qui que ce
soit et notamment de la part des élus
qui sont les premiers concernés
merci je mets donc mathieu rue st
qui a dit je suis contre le pass
sanitaire dans le resto d'ailleurs je me
suis prononcé très tôt il ya des mois
non on n'est pas en train d'installer un
de mettre en place un système de tri des
gens en fonction leur statut sanitaire
vous êtes reconnu monsieur le ministre
mais hier sur ses bancs monsieur pradier
vous a posé une question mais à un
moment où vous étiez absent je pense
utile de vous la reposer parce que c'est
une question pertinente
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire droit
dans les yeux
s'il n'ya pas sanitaires il n'y aura pas
de confinement
on est en train là de s'asseoir sur les
libertés publiques de bouleverser le
droit du travail
est-ce que la contrepartie vous êtes
convaincus de l'efficacité de cette
mesure et pouvait nous regarder droit
dans les yeux on dire avant il n'y aura
pas de confinement ou alors un minimum
est-ce que s'il ya confinement aussitôt
la démonstration de lignes trains
le gouvernement qui est pour compte
rejetée madame ménard et la parole merci
monsieur le président mon amendement
prévoit que la réglementation qui
concerne la mise en oeuvre du pass
sanitaire doit être décidée en
concertation entre le préfet et le maire
de la commune concernée
je vous rappelle que précédemment et
dont les épisodes justement précédentes
cette crise le couple maire préfet ça a
été surtout vécu par les maires comme le
préfet décide et le maire exécute
alors dans cette nouvelle phase de la
crise sanitaire est de plus en plus
tendue et je le regrette
associer pleinement les maires ne
pourrait que vendre les mesures plus
acceptable par les français je vous
remercie
merci défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement madame yade
merci monsieur le président j'avais pris
l'exemple en commission mais je n'avais
pas eu de réponse et je suis sûr que il
n'ya pas que dans un département où je
vais avoir cet exemple il y a plusieurs
exemples où le préfet prend la décision
et où on apprend par voie de presse par
conférence de presse que entendent
parlementaires et les maires c'est la
même que le préfet décide que dans les
communes du département
le masque à partir de telle date
re devient obligatoire ou non non non
arrêté de me dire qu'à des réunions
alors exemple concret département de
meurthe et moselle samedi de la semaine
dernière conférence de presse de
monsieur le préfet dans les communes de
plus de 5000 habitants
le masque devient obligatoire à partir
parce était hier à partir d'hier ni les
maires ni les parlementaires ni les
conseillers départementaux n'ont été vus
avant les journalistes nous appelle pour
nous demander notre avis et là on dit
bah c'est pas je peux au cours on ne dit
pas comment ça vous n'êtes pas au
courant et n'ont n'a pas une réunion
avant donc l'amendement l'oeil très
important sur le papier vous nous dites
si si c'est écrit c'est un décret
le préfet prendra pas de la décision
tout seul oui sur le papier c'est écrit
sauf que ce n'est pas que dans un
département je suis sûr que si là je
demande à qui c'est déjà arrivé vous
serez beaucoup à lever la main les
préfets décident d afrique
ah oui mais j'ai plus le temps de vous
appeler donc non on prend pas la
décision seul en à peine les maires et
les autres élus concernés avant je vais
donc voir 51 kg et pour contre rejeté le
430 je ne vois pas oui mais julien
laferrière pardonnez-moi mais le
supposions celui cela la situation
épidémiologique on le voit elle évolue
rapidement ce qui effectivement vous
pousse à prendre des mesures rapides et
et à convoquer le parlement mais elle
peut demain et évoluer d'une autre façon
et c'est pour ça que l'on va vous
proposer cet amendement qui vise à vous
donner la possibilité de réduire la
liste des établissements concernés par
les nouvelles applications audio pas
signataire en cas d'évolution positive
de la situation
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le fondement de cet abonnement
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
des phares à monsieur ministe
défavorable mais je vois qu'ils aient
pour contre jeter merci monsieur le
président avec cet amendement que j'ai
déjà défendu en commission je propose
que la mise en oeuvre du pass sanitaire
prenne fin dès lors que la circulation
du virus ne représente plus un danger
suffisamment grave pour légitimer son
application
encore une fois il en va de la
lisibilité de la loi alors même si selon
vous j'ai bien entendu ce que vous
m'aviez répondu en commission cet
amendement est selon monsieur le
rapporteur déjà satisfait ce que je
conteste
vu les réactions que j'ai reçus après le
rejet de ce même amendement en
commission
je vous garantis que l'écriture noir sur
blanc dans la loi de cette disposition
rassurerait beaucoup les français et
rendrait ce projet de loi bien plus
acceptable pour la plupart d'entre eux
alors encore une fois c'est une question
lisibilité de la loi encore une fois
c'est une question de précision de la
loi et par conséquent cela devient une
questions d'acceptabilité de votre loi
ce qui est loin d'être le cas pour le
moment je vous remercie
merci défavorable commission
gouvernement je vais devoir me jury
faire moi je pense que sur cet
amendement il doit y avoir une réponse
du ministre c'est à dire quand va cesser
le pass sanitaires on sait très bien que
les dispositions prises en temps
extraordinaires attentatoire à la
liberté ont tendance à se pérenniser
dans des temps plus ordinaire on pense
que cette mesure
elle est contreproductive aujourd'hui en
temps de crise mais par ailleurs quand
est ce que vous comptez la percée c'est
qu'est-ce que vous allez utiliser comme
critère quand on entend le ministre du
numérique qui nous disait que la crise
ouvre une fenêtre d'opportunité pour une
transformation plus volontaire encore on
voit bien que là il ya l'opportunité de
la mise en place d'un libéralisme
autoritaire libéraux avec les
entreprises
autoritaire avec les citoyens et que le
cette manière de deux d'avoir comme
réponse
la matraque la sanction face à un virus
va risque de faire entrer durablement
dans la société
ce qu'on ne souhaite pas inscrire dans
la durée et qu'on souhaite pas voir même
un instant fait
une bonne loi c'est une loi ou le
parlement quand il va t'il et éclairé
alors bon on a compris que le rapporteur
jouez pas au tennis mais 11,2 on se dit
que peut-être le mini show il ya eu
trois questions simples de poser je veux
pas dire à la con parce que première
question est ce que vous garantissez que
la mise en place du développement du
vaccin et du pass sanitaire nous
épargnera le confinement oui non je sais
pas c'est assez simple de répondre
deuxième question est ce que vous pouvez
affirmer devant le parlement que ces
dispositions exorbitante de droit commun
ont un début préoccupant et or ont une
fin est-ce que vous pouvez inscrire
comme fin le fait que quand la situation
sanitaire sera améliorée ces
dispositions exorbitant de droit commun
prendre enfin la réponse aller simple
oui ou non
banon mais répondait donc il ya pas de
réponse ni de celui qui joue pas au
tennis ni de celui qui joue peu trop
trop trop troisième barrette
si vous connaissez la réponse lever la
main et donner la mort mais je ne la
connais pas la réponse est donc je pense
monsieur le président que pour éclairer
nos débats il serait utile que nous
ayons des réponses à ces questions
simples pour quand rejeté le 60d fondu
défavorable commission des faveurs du
gouvernement
mais j'ai eu faim la parole
non mais on va reposer les questions
elles sont simples est-ce que vous
pouvez garantir qu'avec la masse mise en
place de ce pass sanitaires on va pas
voir en plus le confinement à l'automne
[Musique]
alors j'ai entendu là sur les bancs la
majorité des gens me dire ça vaut
toujours le coup d'essayer
comme si c'était une petite chose ouaya
on s'assoit sur les libertés publiques
on demande des papiers à tout le monde
partout et ça serait un petit truc qui
vaut toujours le coup d'être essayée et
la deuxième question on appuie de mon
collègue jumelles on y revient
quand est ce que vous prévoyez la fin de
ce pass sanitaires on ouvre une fenêtre
quand est ce qu on la ferme
merci mais c'est dur quoi la parole oui
merci monsieur le président je me suis
pas exprimé jusque là mais je vous dis
que je suis mais abassourdi parce que ce
qu'on peut entendre
effectivement avec l'attitude qu'on a en
tant que parlementaire à couper les
cheveux en quatre
c'est sûr qu'on va re confinés dans
trois semaines quand on regarde les taux
de contamination de la tranche d'âge 20
40 ans dans trois semaines ça va avoir
diffusé dans le reste de la population
et on va compter les réanimations on va
compter les morts est ce qu aurait agi
mais rapidement
c'est la seule solution qui fonctionne
c'est le vaccin c'est peut-être pas
parfait mais c'est le vaccin est ce
qu'on prend le taureau par les cornes là
mais bien sûr qu'il ya plein de temps
plein de choses qui sont incohérentes
mais on va être tous est responsable de
la catastrophe auquel on va arriver
c'est pas possible de discuter à
l'infini de 2,2 tout ce qui ne va pas
regarder les les taux de contamination
sais je suis moi effaré de notre
incapacité collective à agir rapidement
et plus efficacement
jamais deux voies restantes qui est ou
60 contre rejeté les 896 monsieur
monsieur e
mancka yoba donnez moi merci monsieur le
président c'est un amendement de ma
collègue pour la fortuna qui voulaient
alerter avec cet amendement à la
situation des français de l'étranger qui
n'est pas pris en considération dans
l'élaboration des restrictions liées à
la crise sanitaire
pourtant ce sont des français à part
entière et les mêmes les mesures pas
adapté à ce jour le pass ne reconnaît
pas les vaccins les vaccinations est
administré en dehors de ses frontières
pourtant par des vaccins homologués par
l'union européenne
il doit faire une demande à l'assurance
maladie qui pourra leur donner un
certificat qui ne leur permet pas de la
délivrance d'un qr code et on ne parle
pas des français vaccinés par des
vaccins nono homologué car là rien n'est
prévu nécessaire il est nécessaire que
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
soit en adéquation avec leur situation
je vous remercie
mais les rapporteurs avaient la parole
pour aller dans le sens de ce que disait
le député nicolas turquoise il ya
beaucoup de questions qui sont posées
qui sont en lien avec le texte auquel je
me plie volontiers à l'exercice de
réponse autant que je le peux il ya des
questions qui sont portés à
l'emporte-pièce par des parlementaires
parfois souvent les mêmes pardon de le
dire qu'ils ont trouvé des réponses dans
le débat en commission qui ont trouvé
des réponses dans le débat en hémicycle
une fois deux fois trois fois quatre
fois moi je ne sais plus à quel moment
est ce qu'il faut je vous le dire
continuer de répondre et marteler les
mêmes réponses quand les mêmes questions
sont posées par les mêmes députés ou à
quel moment on attend que l'on n'attend
que ça passe et qu'on ait effectivement
l'occasion de travailler le texte pour
pour dire ce que pour reprendre ce que
disait nicolas turquois quand il dit
qu'il ya une urgence à légiférer les cas
urgents s'applique espace sanitaire
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
bons je les ai pas encore si tu es
aujourd'hui mais 22000 contamination 48%
d'hospitalisation plus sur une semaine
pour ceux qui considèrent qui a pas
d'impact sanitaire et que ça bouge pas
d'hôpital 72% d'admission en plus en
soins critiques et de réanimation en une
semaine
72% certes on part de plus bas d'assez
bas enfin une telle dynamique de
réanimation on l'a pas vu beaucoup dans
les vagues précédentes et pour la
première journée une augmentation de la
mortalité dans notre pays de yoko vide
alors certes à nouveau ça reste une
mentalité qui est beaucoup plus faible
que ce qu'on avait connu mais + 14 %
je faire une réponse globale je vous
fais un réponse globale sur une fin où
je vais faire comme vous monsieur
rifains je hurle dans le micro pour être
sûr que vous entendiez quitte à
sacrifier l'école et apportent tous les
collègues mais vous me posez une
question mur lentilles trois fois je
vous taquine mais pas si vous m'écoutez
par ben cherifa le pass alité argent on
en a besoin tout de suite on en a besoin
tout de suite
est ce que c'est pour solde de tout
compte si quelqu'un vous dit qu'il a la
réponse
il vous dira t il il vous dira des
choses qui relèvent de la prédiction est
pas de là et pas de la modélisation ce
que je suis ce que je sais c'est que
moins mal passé à lithaire plus on a de
risques d'avoir un confinement ça c'est
une certitude
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le passé ni terre on l'appliquera la
durée nécessaire suffisante minimal et
que le premier jour on pourra dire c'est
fini le past and i terre comme on l'a
fait pour les masques en extérieur
messieurs rufin nous le ferons et de la
même manière que nous avons supprimé le
match en extérieur
dès que nous avons pu et j'entends
maintenant vous nous dites qu'on la
supprime est trop tôt je ne doute pas
une seconde que jour on supprimera le
pass sanitaire certains parmi vous qui
étaient contre aujourd'hui nous dirons
que c'est peut-être un peu trop tôt pour
lever la contrainte
bref on n'est pas là pour un nom pour
l'expression pour emmerder les gens on
est là pour les protéger
vous êtes là pour légiférer et on est là
pour avancer résidents mélenchon eva
l'amiral est parti je les suis au
ministre le temps de savourer son
triomphe oratoire qui va lui valoir
la volée de bois vert que vous méritez
collecte sur quoi je je vous estiment
beaucoup mais je vais vous dire la chose
suivante si vous voulez nous rendre
responsables des malheurs qui arriveront
au pays parce qu'on ne vous obéit pas
assez vite à mon tour je pourrais vous
dire que je vous rendrai volontiers
responsable ce que je ne fais pas du
fait que l'on vous a annoncé la deuxième
vague et vous m'avez traité tous les
noms mots je les fais nous vous avons
annoncé la quatrième vague mois d'avril
et mai pas parce que nous étions plus
intelligente tout le monde mais parce
qu'on lisait un peu et vous vous êtes
moquer de nous et que toutes les
décisions que vous avez prises depuis le
début n'ont servi à rien
ça fait donc des mois que ça dure et
cordes compte rendre vous faites tourner
le pays en bourrique en prenant des
décisions qui n'ont aucune sorte des
faits par conséquent quand vous vous
demander jusqu'à quel mouvant on va
discuter quelles qui peut nous tenir
monsieur le ministre le devoir notre
devoir est de faire notre travail de
député qui est d'essayer de convaincre
nos collègues nous essayons de le faire
une fois deux fois trois fois ci un
argument n'est pas beau nous en
présentons un autre parce que nous
sommes convaincus et votre devoir
ne vous en déplaise et de nous répondre
et si c'est possible de le faire sans
trop vous moquez de nous parce que nous
avons aussi du revers puisque vous
annoncer la catastrophe au premier round
moi je vous annonce qu'à la rentrée
prochaine si la situation est telle
qu'elle est qu'avez vous fait pour
prévoir la rentrée scolaire
si jamais la contamination continuent où
est la société par roulement ou et la
division des classes où sont les
épurateurs d'air qui mettez vous au
travail pour produire des bouteilles
d'oxygène dont on a besoin
rien personne vous vous agitez et quand
nous vous demandons quand elle que vous
devez laisser le passage du ter vous
avez une réponse très simple mais assez
solitaire marié dresse à celle appelée
le pass sanitaire parce qu'au guide
guerre ce moment là le pass arènes
dragon grâce à carole
de ceux là mais à la parole merci je
vais essayer de temps je vais essayer
quelque chose je vois ici dans cet
hémicycle tout le monde un ordinateur
quand vous achetez un ordinateur on vous
dit attention vous risquez d'avoir un
virus donc vous achetez un antivirus
quand l'antivirus suffit pas souvent
vous mettez des pare feux et vous faites
très attention de ne pas attraper le
virus
bon le pass sanitaires c'est l'autre
antivirus mais parfois parfois parfois
vous savez que vous attraper quand même
un virus bien que vous ayez un antivirus
est ce qu'on veut nous essayons de faire
avec ce pass sanitaires c'est d'éviter
justement à nouveau de voir confiné tout
simplement donc si nous réussissons si
nous arrivons nous en tant qu'élus et
chacun dans nos territoires et c'est ce
que je m'emploie à faire c'est d'essayer
de convaincre d'essayer d'expliquer la
vaccination plutôt que de lire des fake
news
si nous arrivons ensemble à permettre
que toutes les personnes qui doivent se
faire vacciner arrive à se faire
vacciner alors nous aurons réussi c'est
tout ce que nous souhaitons merci je
vais devoir lutter 96 des forts que nous
étions gouvernement qui est pour contre
rejeté présent ce soir 21h30 suivi
projet de loi relative à la gestion de
la crise sanitaire séance est levée